go follow it
the second period
so subscribe to the channel and okay
like the video because that is the most
important live stream so if you want to
push up the message like the video
so
today we have a very very interesting
channel so
um
london
uh
hi i
am in a relationship
hi guys
i'm originally from indonesia
and i'm in a relationship
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay so
today we're talking about
so
so i first wanted to ask
do
women need attention to survive
yes or no just a yes or no yeah yeah you
could any thoughts you have on this
question
um
i think
yeah there is definitely an innate
craving for
attention validation from people in
general or from men um
in terms of survival
i think that's a complicated one it
varies i suppose
do you guys think
i don't think they need attention to
survive
[Laughter]
maybe water
but um
i don't think that's a female thing i
feel like people need attention right
there's like a load of people
that need attention and they're just
needy people
yeah i think they needed it
that's why when they hit the wall they
like implode
absolutely a woman won't go to three
hours to turn myself up for no attention
that don't make any sense
absolutely yeah they literally evaporate
if they don't get enough attention
so um i have a question for the met
do you feel like women are more
interested when you give them attention
or not
oh gosh so in the current dating market
i think
it's complicated because a lot of people
are used to toxic relationships so often
from experience what i've seen is
if you do
if there if there are certain women who
are
receiving quite a lot of attention and
on a regular basis you know they're very
attractive what can tend to happen is if
they sense a sense of desperation or you
trying to try too hard
they can tend to pull away but then if
you step back yourself
they can tend to desire more it's almost
like that phenomenon of
people wanting what they can't have
so
yeah it just depends i suppose
um women live for attention
absolutely
they can't get enough of it
and and
i'll give it an example i had a friend
i was working from home and she comes
when i was working from home and because
i was working not paying attention she's
turning a tantrum i don't know what
you're not working from one before you
came here i'm not gonna leave working so
they can't get enough of it it's like
i'm petrol in the car
yeah i actually
i posted like a youtube short about this
that's how passionate i am yesterday
and my theory is
that the modern woman is a narcissist
and that they can only bond
via
men's time and attention and that's that
that that theory underpins all your
success in dating
um the reason why you can't talk to him
so much you have to play these games of
attention and status when you text
someone unhindered tinder
is is because of that it's because
it doesn't matter what you say she's not
actually interested in you there's like
20 people that match with her she's what
she's trying to do she's trying to she's
going to fall in love with herself via
the proxy of your time and attention
that's why it's better that she you talk
20 and she talks 80
because she doesn't care what you do
so
that's my theory is that what you put in
your youtube channel yeah i was just
like this is why masculine men don't
talk much it's pointless
like you're insecure
yeah
uh only 200 views so far but i'm gonna
get roasted i'm waiting for it you've
been shadow bent
you know it's funny um because i always
hear guys say that like when you give
like when you pull back then like girls
will come at you stronger and harder
would you say that's true absolutely
yeah
i think it i mean generally in terms of
yeah the toxic dating environment that
does tend to be the case but for people
who are stable
which is rarer these days
yeah
um sometimes they're not interested in
playing games they just want a man who's
actually going to get injured
yeah yeah that's that's for women who
aren't most of them
yeah but that's just toxic in your
experience
the only reason they chase you back is
because they want the validation so to
that process is just getting them hooked
on the validation do you think that's
the case for every woman yeah period
yeah well well stable woman won't won't
let a conversation be that one-sided so
so there'll be an equal sense of loss
but when you're mismatching someone a
hinge or tinder yeah you've been making
her feel like the most fascinating sexy
woman on the planet and you've stopped
texting after a while she's going to be
like yeah
so what question what games have you
used that worked games yeah that worked
i think i've given up on games i think
probably in my earlier less mature
stages yeah okay it could be from a
while ago it doesn't mean you're
currently doing it okay from a while ago
probably
yeah that you know trying to play it
cool not trying to do too much you know
making sure that you don't do things
like double texting you know making sure
that you're trying to keep that interest
from this you know what the dane gurus
will tell you pull back don't don't give
too much don't don't sound too desperate
play game you know that kind of thing
yeah why because that was before though
but like don't you think that that's the
kind of people you're going to attract
if that's what you're out there doing
and i'm i'm saying i hear that you're
not doing that anymore
but
that was a response to the women though
yeah
that's what i'm saying like man it
wasn't i wanted to just be me but every
time
you kind of just be you obviously you
have that phenomenon of she's texting
how many different guys right that's how
that's how it so then you're trying to
almost compete
but then she's getting all the time so
the normal
influx of attention attention attention
doesn't it's like when people are
watching corn mm-hmm you know um
generally they get bored of the thing
they've watched yesterday and then they
want to watch something else so because
of the attention span so that that you
know normal span of attention you're
giving isn't being appreciated as much
until you change something about it to
make it more interesting well i don't i
think men like they don't do anything
unless women require it
so like if women if women complain about
men like like playing games or whatever
like men don't do anything that doesn't
work
so it's like if women required that men
take them on like
like 30 dates before they slept with
them men would do it but it's like
when they do that and it doesn't work
then they change what they're doing so
if like a guy's being in this in this
scenario right if a guy's being nice
and giving girls tons of attention and
it's not working they change what
they're doing
so like the state of men is a reflection
of women
i definitely agree with it that's true
men will jump through hoops to get laid
before before the development of birth
control they would literally marry a
girl to get laid
and i've and i've talked to older like
men about this and they're like yeah i
got married so i could get laid
you can literally learn the gain from
women as well
so the women women play much more
sophisticated games with each other than
we do so you actually learn about the
meaning of the double text from women
when they talk when she's like oh yeah
stacy wants to come over and she texts
me twice she's like really begging it
that kind of stuff
but i had two strategies right there was
one where i was like me
nerdy i was like yeah i like this anime
yeah you know speaking in his poetry and
whatever not cheesy stuff but like you
know just
add a lot of things so that you can have
a conversation from right if you really
want to talk to me i've given you like
20 things here my favorite movie my
favorite color i've made a joke here
that didn't work so then i tried the
games right short texts take time in
between text match her time because
women notice this if you apply too
quickly they notice they think you're
lame
um and then women got super attached
when i did that but there's one girl i
was talking for like a day
and then i took like 15 minutes to add
her number on what's happened she
blocked me and i was like she was
investing fam
like
all i did was ask her about her dog i
was like oh does he slobber hahaha sexy
or whatever yeah so
wait so you got blocked well she yeah
she blocked me on whatsapp and um on the
hinge because yeah she gave me a number
is that is that a good sign to get
blocked yeah that's what i mean like are
you sure that's why she blocks you
massively yeah because she shows she was
invested so if you gave me a number
we're like yeah let's hang out and i i
add it and text you the next day and
you've blocked me by then it must have
meant she felt she felt silly because
she gave me a number and i didn't text
her for a while or she blocked you
because she was like [ __ ] i've given
this guy my number and i don't want to
like no disrespect to you but like
no yeah what i've discovered though is
um
with women because they love attention
if you if you say tell me about yourself
and just listen
for the next two hours she can go on but
okay guys do you not think maybe this is
like the women that you're attracting
because you're saying you're looking for
these girls on dating apps but you're
only gonna like i'm not taking all women
on dating apps by the way
but you're you're like you're attracting
a very specific type of woman like
you're not like well i think the point
is women like to talk more than men yeah
so it's just a biological difference
like i don't remember what the
percentage is but we use so many more
words in a day than men
yeah women use at least 20 000 words a
day compared to 7 000 that men use
so
what's that message the woman talk is
measured on the impact of your words
yeah if as a man if you're always
talking you undermine yourself because
people think you're you're silly firstly
people are always judging you by what
you say if i walk into a room of guys
and i'm like ha ha hey guys i like this
that this that they're watching me
thinking this guy's cheesy they can say
a hundred things about me they can cost
you for anything you've just volunteered
same with women
have you been ever ever been attracted
to a guy who talks a lot
yeah my boyfriend talks a lot lies no he
does he's that like he chats a lot talk
to you now now
what do you mean he talks more you or
him
if we asked him what would he say he
could definitely
but however he's definitely chatty
because he's like he's a comedic person
well i mean i think like people attract
right you're correct but i think what
we're saying is in general women talk
more and even if you talk to your
boyfriend he would probably say when he
was pursuing you that he let you talk
and then to say because you said you
said on dating i met a girl in a boss
and a boss okay i offered up what
happened i offered up popcorn she said
no okay
the next day i saw her in town center
uh-huh i finally met her once in the bus
she told me all a live history
and i just stood and just listened
and each time she kept on saying i don't
know why i'm telling you this and then
she got one
she's one of them some people are like
that though some people you literally
meet them for two seconds guys or girls
and they will tell you their life story
yeah cause women like women love to talk
and like attention and i just won my
attention and she loved it so i have
another question do you think women like
being objectified absolutely
absolutely
some of them
i think
yeah there is not all of them yes it's
definitely not all of them i think it's
a sense of yeah going back to that
attention thing if they are craving that
attention
there are times when they want to
i think actually there's this i asked
the girl this actually one time and she
said
she likes to to be objectified or or
receive attention from the guy she likes
yeah yeah
the men she doesn't like i don't want it
she yeah i don't need it that creeps and
you know really i appreciate all
compliments
i don't know why
i don't get a legit though like one day
i'm just saying one day you're going to
be 55. no one's going to be
complimenting you
i'm going to be a mouth so yeah
are men lined up to date 55 year olds
what about guys that love milfs like
there's definitely guys up there that
love an old woman dude okay do you guys
like do you guys want to date a 55 year
old no you wanna okay yeah i would i'll
sleep with a 55 year old depending on
the situation
but i wouldn't stand here and be like
yeah that's what i'm looking for what
about if she's bath
yeah i'll smash yeah but you wouldn't
like okay someone who's someone that's
like i don't know jennifer aniston buff
yeah
you're looking for the exception like
that's like the one like those are those
are celebrities those are celebrities do
you have celebrity money to maintain
that stuff no
okay but there's plenty of people
that look good okay do you think the
average 55 year old woman yeah men are
lined up to date her
i don't know it's a quick note i don't
know
how do you know she doesn't want peace
women
women don't want peace emotions they
want trouble always
always i don't want peace i want
problems yeah boy i don't like peace
nice guys like trouble i mean why do you
think women are always talking about men
are trash because you're sleeping with
the trash man
but i feel i feel like it's like a celeb
oh every girl has a toxic ex-boyfriend
i feel like but do you have a toxic
ex-boyfriend ah we all do
that's what i'm saying
but do you know what i think it is i
think every girl and i'm not like i'm
not saying that every girl was a nice
girl but i feel like every girl goes
through that stage of having that toxic
boyfriend
and they'll either grow out of it
they'll go that was a [ __ ] scenario i
will never do that again and they learn
from that and they
go to someone that's better
or they can continually perpetuate that
same relationship over and over again so
i feel like sometimes if you're a nice
person sometimes you attract that toxic
person because they're like
go ahead i don't have a toxic boyfriend
because i just can't deal an ex we're
talking about not currently no like ex
never yeah yeah yeah first boyfriend
is it because i'm just like so cute i
just really don't i can't stand like
stupidity
i really can't like it doesn't make
sense like i had a guy that i was dating
like he blocked me and i just dropped it
because it was just dumb like i don't
would you say that you would you say
you're the exception more than the rule
yeah for sure yeah yeah i have no
patience because i just feel like what's
the point if you're not going to end up
together yeah how did you develop
that value system to not have to not
tolerate you know a toxic guy
you have a good family did you have a
good example no it's more like i had bad
experiences with friends
and then i took that into romantic
relationships as well okay but you had
toxic friends so essentially you had
like
a similar
toxic friends dropped it learned from it
never had a bad really yeah i would
argue it's your culture though i think a
lot of asian women in asia the dating
game is a bit different because they
they value intelligence a bit more and
more like um blue blue color kind of
things i i don't really see many like i
had a chinese girlfriend a thai
girlfriend they don't really go for bad
boys they want the guy who got a job at
google
that's who they that's who they talk
about in uni
no it's true they don't bash men either
yeah they don't get the whole feminism
thing actually if i had like a bad
boyfriend my mom would like
not give me a break and my dad would
think i'm dumb
like i don't want my parents to think
yeah that's like i feel like everything
in dating is your own fault yeah
absolutely
so if um if women always say they don't
like to be objectified then why do they
wear makeup
because i like to look cute why do you
wear makeup
to look better
yeah
what's that what's the you don't want to
be objectified right no i'm fine with it
no but women i'm just saying like i like
people finding me attractive i don't
know like i don't i don't want people to
like you know be repulsive yeah be like
weird with it but like i think it's like
lying to say you don't wear makeup for
other people at all yeah i think with
you you're obviously being honest about
it whereas a lot of women will be like
we're doing it for us like i'm doing it
for myself for three hours don't go
straight lie to your face
straight up lie to your face
no because if i was home alone i'd look
homeless
[Music]
so i'm not gonna say i don't look good
for other people
but
other people but like just for men
do you know what i mean is it like most
of the time like i dress up because i
want another girl telling me that like
my outfit's cute not because like i want
a guy to come over to me and like try
and chat to me well it's based on what
guys like
uncle and women too
and women too question for you right if
you met up in cute outfits with your
friends and you all had makeup yeah what
would you go and do together
chill sure you want you want good
clubbing or see any other guys you just
you just work cute outfits and make up
just uh just to chill out and girl lolly
parties
and what and girl anybody
see do you know what yeah i'm so sick of
voice saying this because girls get
dressed and go to dinner together girls
get dressed and go and chill where men
can check them out because it's funny
because come on
you're telling me at a girls night where
you're drinking wine
and you're at the house you're not
leaving the house at all yeah that women
get dressed up the same than if they're
going to a club yeah
who do you hang around
like people people dress different when
more eyes are on them
so you're telling me you're telling me
in
seriously i'm telling you honestly all
seriously your friends your friends go
go to your apartment to hang out and
wear the same thing they would wear to a
club
i mean we're not like we're not in like
stilettos but we're like we're dressed
nice we've got our hair done we've got
our makeup done we're having dinner
like a cap i don't know why i don't know
i'm not gonna go i'm not gonna go to
dinner at my girl's house
pictures
but you dress up right yeah
dress and you wear makeup yeah what for
your girlfriend yeah no come on stop it
why not no
are you one of those women like like you
you don't you think it doesn't mean
anything if someone like pays for you or
something like that what do you mean
well i i have my own money so i i don't
need you to pay for me
yeah
i work
yeah but most
woman yeah kind of thing um
yeah i guess i think like i've just
always been raised
to be able to pay my own way like if my
boyfriend wants to pay for something
then obviously i'll offer but if he says
no no it's on me then cool but like i
don't need anyone to pay anything for me
like i can pay for myself so do you know
um behind makeup like there's biological
reasons that we wear them so
yeah so it's like so how can we say it's
not for other people when you're
signaling sexual arousal i've heard this
i don't know where that like is that
what it like yeah because it's like
during sex your your lips are red that's
why there's red lipstick and it's like
it's same with yeah blush on the cheeks
because you look younger yeah more
attractive
and i heard i heard that women wear red
because
they put red on what what they want men
to notice
oh interesting yeah so that's why a
woman would wear a red dress
and red makeup
sort of a woman to man
red
you see red from anyway
yes definitely
inciting
and you're more likely to wear red when
you're ovulating too
cute
i'm bleeding by the way i'm also red
but there's one thing that you there's
something that you refer to prefer to
understand the women's practice um self
objectification
where
the image that you portray is what we
see
so if you dress up in a way that
suggests that all you want is
sex that's what we see
yeah but they don't yeah but they'll
they'll convince themselves but you're
gonna say yeah i'm doing this for myself
for me i think the dating
dating is a gateway to three
marketplaces so you've got the section
marketplace the relationship marketplace
and the marriage marketplace so when the
woman dresses up as a guy at one look at
her in five seconds i can tell which of
those marketplace she wants me to
see
by just looking at the way she dress
and most men are like me
so how has that worked out for you so
far just like not in an offensive way
but how is that so you put these women
into these three categories
um how has that worked out for you so
far are you now in a you said you're
single so how's that putting them into
those three marketplaces by judging them
by the way that they've dressed as that
worked out for you well i used to be
married i was married for 20 years okay
so when that ended i decided okay forget
marriage let me just do this sexual
marketplace thing that was brilliant it
was liberating and all that but i then
got to a point where
i think you know woman is too much
trouble
but it's true women even the nicest one
comes along and because i'm a nice guy a
girl told me that i'm too nice and
because of that i'm vulnerable
and she's trying to take advantage of me
so
okay fine i will come and find you when
i need you you can't you can't shame him
by like implying like that as personal
life because that's kind of what you're
doing i'll tell you but what i'm saying
but i'm saying like because that's how
men are is they they categorize women by
like the way you present
yeah like the same way girls will
categorize men by the way they if they
look like a bummer they're wearing a
suit
and there's another thing that you don't
realize when you spend three hours doing
yourself up and you come out
it's from my point of view it's good for
your mental health if i look at you and
make comments because otherwise that
would be a waste of three hours of your
life if i don't see anything it's polite
yeah i don't think so do you know what i
don't think so that's how it works so i
see you're thinking oh she spent so much
time let me give her a compliment you
look nice even if i don't want anything
with you
yeah like because if if a girl is
dressing in a way that's seeking
attention how could she be mad when she
gets it
so if you're if you're dressing in a way
where your ass is out your boobs are out
you're a full face of makeup and then
someone compliments you you're mad
with more homes you could you couldn't
you could have dressed like like
i don't get compliments when i go out in
my sweats
like
so we can't change the
outcome for our actions that's the thing
if we do something people are going to
perceive it one way or another but i
think a lot of yeah i think that i tend
to think that
you know you shouldn't just because i'm
dressed the same way doesn't mean that's
who i am and that might be true but the
thing is people
judge by the first few seconds of what
they see especially men when it comes to
deciding is this
do i see this person as a wife to me or
do i see
um this person as somebody who might be
good for a hookup or whatever people but
what women don't realize is you
think a man thinks like you so you then
think okay i want to be a wife and then
you're dressed like a slot and the one's
looking at you i'm thinking oh this is a
slot
and most men will not be honest enough
to tell you that yeah the truth is
there's a saying right clothing is a
dress of thought you can tell a lot
about someone by
how they wear their clothes the kind of
clothes they wear so and i think women
understand this women
women understand women are extremely
women know this stuff very very well i i
think women like talk to each other and
they're like
could i convince this guy that this guy
is actually green
like if i can do this
that i wore this g string just because i
like g strings i did it for me
i wore a thong bikini for myself
they're so comfortable though you get
like less tan lines
[Laughter]
why do you want that big white patch all
the way across your bum
do you know what i mean so
what the same for men
because i remember i got stopped by the
police and they probably said to me do
you know what i'll stop you and i said
no
and they gave me this [ __ ] about
your car's got no mit and i'm dressed in
shirt on trousers
then they stop another black guy it came
out it's got his jeans on his pants
showing oh that's my brother and the way
they treated him um i would literally
stand inside each other the way they
treated him was completely different
they tricked me with respect
they told his car away they found two
votes on my car and they gave me an
option which i found strange they said
you got an option i said what's that
said three points or you go and change
the tire
and i think are you serious he said yeah
so i went i said i'll change the time
they didn't give a boy they didn't give
me any option at all they found one foot
in this car they brought the tow truck
and took it away
and it didn't didn't see anything it
wasn't rude it was just the way he
dressed do you think do you not judge
people at all by the way they're dressed
so if a dude comes in a very nice
expensive suit you don't assume he has a
better job than a homeless man on the
street i mean the assumption on the like
on the job front yeah i get it right i
get that like maybe this person's so you
can make assumptions such as like maybe
they have more money or maybe you don't
think a girl that wears less clothes and
posts her ass on the internet has a
higher need for attention than someone
who doesn't
you know that everyone's needy though
like if you're online posting pictures
you're needy anyway
so could you answer the question yeah
yes or no
do you think a girl that posts your ass
on the internet
needs more attention than someone who
doesn't
depends
you could say yes and then explain or
know and then explain okay um
no and i'll explain okay right
because you can
i feel like you can know yourself
i'm not saying i don't know how to like
word it
you can know yourself
and
depend it depends what you use your
social media for right that's the way
i'm going about it because if you're
just if you're just like an average
person and you're just
you're just randomly taking pictures of
yourself naked and then posting them on
instagram then yeah i would say that is
for attention okay but if you're like i
don't know if you're if you've got a
swimsuit collection
and you've got a business
then
i don't think you you could have a model
do that just have to be you
you could just pay someone to do it or
that there's a lot of it it will still
be someone that's naked on your
instagram though yeah but it wouldn't be
you yeah
so you still stand by the no
she's just trying to dance around the
question yeah sounds good
i want to say it's 50 50. can i say it's
15
minutes what percent what percent of
women do you think own a swimsuit
collection everyone
oh wait a swimsuit collection
out of a hundred women how many owners
from school actually just out of a
hundred women how many own a swimsuit
collection at night probably like one
okay so why why are you standing on the
50 50 then because i just don't think
that like why do you post pictures of
yourself when you're at the beach you
want to like for attention like why
would you post any you could send a
picture to the people you want to send
it to like your friends and family why
do anything on the internet you know i
think it'd be weirder from one of my
friends sent text me a picture of her at
the beach than if i saw it online but
i'm saying it's for attention regardless
it's for attention from someone you
could just take the pictures to have
other like why would you post it if you
didn't want other people to see it and
get attention from it yeah okay i think
what the issue is is that it's become a
culture so when you've been doing
something for so long you forget the
reason why you're doing it
until you actually reflect and think
deeply or you're questioned like how you
are right now but
do you know what like i think going back
to what you said you you're saying
there's something so bizarre about men
that will randomly say things to you as
you're walking through the street i do
all the time yeah but why it depends on
what you say why because it's like it's
not warranted like if i'm literally
sometimes drake came up to you on the
street
i don't fancy drake like that sorry
who's someone you fancy you get that you
get what i'm trying to know what you're
trying to say but like like listen to
what i'm saying right so if i'm like
every day i'm like rush it like i'm
person
don't want to say i'm late on the
internet [ __ ] it
every day i'm like speed walking to the
tube right
like at a solid pace so it doesn't look
like i want to talk to anyone it doesn't
look like i'm trying to grab the
attention of anyone i'm not like swaying
do you know what i mean i'm i'm going
somewhere and there is always someone
that's like hello
oh babes uh and you're just like why
like why it sounds so horrible i can't
imagine like what that's like
something like that you like that do you
like i just don't care i don't like this
to be if someone if someone if someone
comes back if someone compliments me
like why would i get offended they're
complimenting you just say take the
compliment and go
like i just feel like you're going out
of your way to get offended
why'd you like why like
you're wasting your energy it's just
like okay night thanks and then you keep
going even if even if he's creepy it's
like they're calling they're saying
something nice to you it's a thing to do
as well
they're just shooting their shots
honestly i don't like it like one day
one day it'll be like 70 and you'll be
like begging people to shoot their shot
but that's like how guys i don't need it
that's how guys do it like as much as
possible until like yeah hands on
someone
that's
how they do it like they wouldn't they
wouldn't do it if it didn't work
sometimes
yeah i guess
like how did you and your boyfriend get
together how did he approach it we met
at a games night and he said hello right
and we said and we just started chatting
with someone asking a result i started
conversation no because i don't even
actually remember how the conversation
started we were in a group
setting and someone said something and
someone else said something else
and that's how it like no one was like
oh you look cute oh yeah okay so if
you're if your boyfriend came up to you
and said you look very nice this is like
i'm whatever his name is
he wouldn't you wouldn't
if he came up to me when you look very
nice no no he says that like in a nice
way so you like like he gave you a
compliment yeah you would be offended i
wouldn't be offended but i feel like if
you're just randomly muttering things at
me as i'm walking through the streets i
feel like why well he doesn't have to
randomly mutter but you know what i mean
that's what that's what my situation is
but i'm saying like
like this is why guys say women are
confusing and they don't like nice guys
that's true but do you think it's nice
to be like okay absolutely
if you're walking down the street
i'll tell you my theory on this and this
this is this is a theory in progress
it's kind of weak well i i think of it
as emotional magnification so like i
have this idea that and i'm still this
is this is a weak theory but women like
to feel as emotional about things as
possible right they want to avoid logic
because if you can explain something
simply then it's not it's not arousing
emotionally you can't be aroused about
like maths or physics however if you get
a compliment from someone that's
positive then you can then choose like
whatever narrative in your head feminist
narrative and say now i get to feel
offended and then when you transmit that
story you can then add another dimension
to it so you can add as many different
dimensions so that's that's my view of
why women tend to make very simple
things as intense and like dramatic as
possible because they rather feel than
think
but to me it's uncomfortable if some if
i'm walking behind someone it makes me
feel uncomfortable but you're in control
of your emotions you should be anyway
but you're allowing it to feel you make
you feel uncomfortable yeah yeah but
that's what i'm saying like you can just
say okay and then mind you like go on
with your day but you're choosing to let
it get to you it's a choice but i'm like
i'm allowed to not like it you're
allowed to not like it but i'm saying
like you're choosing to focus on it okay
let me ask you a question if you dress
up you wear you've gone you got no money
you put your best dress on your best
makeup and you go outside and for the
whole day not one single person give you
a compliment how do you feel
even the people that you know
not one single person i don't know i
just wouldn't care
what if it happened for about a week or
something in a month you have so much
cap
need to be right type yeah this is need
to be right like in action
but like i just i don't know i just
wouldn't care
like how how are men supposed to know
how to approach women
like how are they supposed to know what
each woman likes to be approached and
doesn't like to be approached i guess
you can feel it
no you can tell by like energy you know
you can feel it notice can you not tell
by like energy you can feel it okay no
english
man man i just have a question can you
can you just feel it yeah you can't
absolutely
i gave you a compliment and i tried to
escalate to like a meeting and that
failed horribly most of the time so
telling me that there's a feeling
and it's like confusing to men because
you're out here getting offended i'm
like i love the compliments keep going
and so it's like
man
it's the thing it's not really it's two
different people but you can feel that
way and that's fine there's nothing
wrong with the way you feel and there's
nothing wrong with the way i feel it's
just that
it's just everyone's different but i'm
saying what okay
this is this is the whole post-modern
thing that's going on now that people
feel that they're entitled to their own
version of reality so i can feel any way
about anything and technically that's a
valid point of view so i used to i used
to have this opinion in university where
like you know i was quite popular in my
final year of university i i figured out
in my uni when i was like these guys for
the shirt i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
do this and so i'll talk to these girls
take them out on like you know
semi dates and they'll be in my room and
things would escalate from there and i
would just watch how each one would
approach it so some of them were cool
but some of them would be in the room
and they were awkward but when women are
awkward they try and make you feel
awkward so that because they're they're
in the strong position right so there
was this one girl in my bed under my
sheets
cheeks on me and then she was like just
because i'm here doesn't mean i want to
have sex and i was like sorry
no i literally grilled her on this i was
like she's actually a long time this is
what made her my friend because i was
like hold on so so what are we doing why
are you why are you under my sheets
right now she was like well maybe you
know it doesn't have to be about sex
then why are you on under my sheets why
is your butt on my groin right now
the point being bedtime story that
there is no like separate version of
reality you're entitled to those there
are social norms and there are kind of
things where behaviors are appropriate
behaviors expected and behaviors are
incorrect
so that last time do you know the
privilege you have to be able to
complain when people compliment you
what do you mean
what do i mean do you know the privilege
that you have to be able to complain
when people compliment you
like being getting complimented is a
privilege you're a pretty girl not
everybody gets compliments there's fat
chick there's whales every day that go
unnoticed i hate that don't come in
whales but that's what they are no
they're not it's what they are not what
am i supposed to call someone that's
over 300 pounds that's just all who they
are well
what would you call them
she's a human being that's a whale she's
not
oh i could be so on my days
now they'll put her on the cover of
cosmo we'll call it beautiful
maybe
to who she is to who to who
to whoever's looking at her like i don't
feel like you have to be a certain size
to be beautiful i don't feel yeah i feel
okay i don't think
that you have to be a certain size
to be beautiful
yeah you don't but i don't think so but
there's reality and there's okay there's
because you look the way you look
there's this many guys knocking on your
door if you were 300 pounds there'd be a
lot less guys knocking on your door
it depends what guys i'm into you know
depends if they'd like a chunky girl no
it's true
i grew up i grew up fat and then i lost
weight and i was like super skinny okay
and
it was actually getting annoying how
many guys were coming up to me now that
i've gained weight again
i'm like oh chill i like it this way
i personally don't like
people bothering me
but i'm not gonna blame them for trying
i'm just like okay you tried chill just
don't touch me
and don't like hurt me that's it it's
fine i'm coming for some asian woman
absolutely
if they don't harass you i just do not
see the problem but a lot of them do
harass you and this is why i wouldn't
call harassment everything like women
call women are like the biggest softies
when it comes to harassment like none of
y'all have been really harassed okay i
go i'll give i'll give you a couple
compliments and maybe maybe he'll keep
going with it they'll be like oh my god
harassment i'm like he just complimented
you a couple times let me give you an
example okay okay so
one day i live the tube is here so i've
got two tube stations where i live right
so there's one here literally next to
the apartments i live by and there's one
over there right i i'm literally running
again to work
running to the
to the tube
and this guy starts running besides me
and he's like he's like he's like miss
miss miss miss and he's trying to talk
to me and i said to him like excuse me
like i'm i'm literally i'm running late
i've got no time to talk to you
he said i just want to tell you look
nice i said okay thank you cool
i've still got to go to work right bye
left the next day he sees me again
it's the same thing obviously i'm not
running to the train station this day
and i say to him that i've got a
boyfriend i'm not interested he's like
your boyfriend doesn't have to know you
can come to you can come to my place i'm
die no
i'm not interested the next day again he
sees me and he sees me he's here
and he he said and again it's the same
thing
daily
daily for a week like
do you not think that's harassment
that's just one guy right no but the p
point did you not think he was also
going to work though maybe that's why
he's bumping onto into you daily at the
same time he's just like like he's like
i just would not care
like i just okay just don't reply yeah
then just keep that harassment
if you've repeatedly told a guy i'm not
interested i don't want anything to do
with you some someone call it someone
call that persistence
i grew up in nigeria and if i come to
you and i approach and you said no and
i'll ask you a simple question what
percentage of chance have i got if you
said two percent that's good enough i've
got something to work with
you're crazy
you should be like you do you hear that
like they've been like like there's so
much like there's so much privilege of
being able to say like
man
like that men approach me every day that
doesn't happen to everyone yeah and so
it's like it's like you're complaining
about
that
but don't you think that women in
general get approached more
anyway yeah boohoo but
who cares you don't have to like it
you don't have to like it but you don't
have to let it bother you like you're
like letting it bother you as a choice
yeah are you reflected i'm pretending
it's like harassment or something that
someone sees you and compliments you it
is harassment because you don't know how
it's going to go you don't know if it's
going to like escalate to something else
so
you think this guy is going to kidnap
you on your way to work
you look
that's a horror story that's like going
to the extreme it's not the north you
know your percentage chance of getting
kidnapped and killed is do you know how
many women died this year
do you know how many people i have
strangers in my apartment four times a
week you'll be fine
you'll be fine you'll be surprised maybe
it's given himself maybe give himself 10
chances right it's gonna approach you
ten times and if you say no nine times
the ten times you might say yes so it's
gonna persist for those ten times and at
the tenth time you say no then it's
gonna walk away do you know i think
that's just like wearing women down or
like wearing people down i say it was
the opposite way so it was a woman going
after a man okay let's just take the 52
women out of the millions
52. 52 women died this year yeah do you
know there was a big number no are you
worried about people that died
emotional magnification
how many how many
how many women do you not think that's a
big number no
not not not one percent of the uk's
people you're complaining because one
guy likes you
do you know how bizarre that sounds
right you know what i think it is is
that
4.496 million women and 52 died
how many women sorry 4.9 or 4.49 so 4.5
million women in london yeah that's a
lot of people in 50s who died am i is
this going to keep me up at night crying
scared
still a lot of people 52 people
this is like need to be right because
it's not you know it's not like like i'm
talking to you as an adult right as an
adult
like we could say 52 women out of 4.5
million is not a lot
yes
yeah i get that but it's still like it's
still
it's not
it's not a lot in the comparison but i
still think that like 52
people dying they're still a bit mad no
not enough to scare me
i think more people get killed by
dolphins
dolphins grape i mean yeah
yeah crazy dolphin
i was gonna look up like how many people
died from like a car crash or something
look up how many people died from
dolphin grapes how many people died
from dolphin
attacks
uh
i don't there's no number that's coming
up
okay so
why do we tell women to never settle
women don't certainly don't you don't
say that though women say that to
themselves and then they pretend that's
what everyone else is saying
western women by the way not the age of
asians do you think they're what what
age should women just look around and
grab the first guy she can
22
22 22. but at 22 you've graduated right
you've been through the whole school
system you've seen what's up there
you've probably tried a little bit of
clubbing that little bit of cabin is
most likely a direct representation of
what it's going to continue to be like
so i would say that's probably a good
time to be like all right let me just
jump this curve if you're clever or if
you're mentally like healthy if you're a
narcissist
you're going to be like well i'm great
so i'm going to wait out until someone
realizes how great i am i'm going to go
to better bars where better men will be
and for some reason they'll love me
because i'm the center of the universe
and that's how they reach the wall
i'm american you're gonna the chat's
gonna turn on you they're going to hate
me no they're going to love you today
they said that was a feminist they're
going to no they hated you last time
they'll love you today
people don't know like
okay americans got that thing they call
dom 25 where you can do all the dumping
you can think of when you but when you
get 25 it's that bit like an adult
so i would suggest that when you get 25
then get married
yeah i think because you've gone you've
done all the dumb stuff
yeah i think the problem is um what's
been advertised to women a lot is
you know enjoy your 20s
you know party do all of these things so
that you don't you know miss out on the
fun kind of thing and so they get to the
almost like 30 years old and above
and you know the reality hits which is
that most men
tend to want to date younger women and
yeah for fertility attractiveness all of
those other things and also less baggage
which is crucial to us
um
but yeah i think yeah a lot of it's a
bit of a scam
i mean you're left over after 35 right
apparently
but once you get to 29 you're not
married and you just trouble ahead
straight yeah you're left over like
twenty seven yeah
you're left over like 27 28 in my scene
at that time
you're kind of like yeah it's crazy you
know what the average age of first
marriage is in the uk 27. uh-uh 31. i
thought you wanted 31. 31 in the uk it's
20 years yeah unless they will have been
together before they get to that one
i don't know i don't i don't know what
the numbers are
but even if they dated for like three
years before that's still 29. yeah but i
think the best advice you can give away
money is find yourself a man yeah i
agree i agree with you i'm not like same
page i'm just like saying it's
interesting because that's the average
age of first marriage
i think the problem that women have got
is you the
voices in your echo chamber is just so
deceiving
you just lie to each other yeah i think
women actually like they actually
believe their own lives at some point
you ever had that when you argue with
someone who's so psychotic that like she
actually convinces herself what she's
saying makes sense
whatever whatever hits this mind the
most will rule it that's it yeah yeah
whether you listen to it
even when you bring out the stats and
the stats are right there they ignore
that i feel i feel
and you can't you can't you can't even
have a discussion with feelings a
perfect example is like some of these
like kevin samuel kind of videos where
he got famous because if he said someone
was average at best this woman was below
average by the way it would be nice
well below average but he was like
he was like your average at best because
she was either you know the whole talk
i've got a business you know i want a
higher value man this woman looked like
a llama fam but
she was like you're average at best and
then he was he was called a hater he was
like oh you're beating down women i was
like why is telling someone that you
look like a normal person an insult yeah
it's because yeah when did that become
an insult average most people are
average narcissists are always special
though
every narcissist is like the top you are
making
a lot of facts tonight no i was thinking
about it this morning i had a
conversation with my husband i i figured
it out i had a lack of that's why i
started this youtube channel keep going
keep going i was just i started this
youtube channel so your theory is so
most modern women are narcissists why um
because they think about it this way
you're a female right you've grown up
your whole life being told you're the
center of the world every film was about
romance every action film the superstar
has to get a woman some woman somewhere
um now this whole feminist thing so you
don't have to be accountable now it's
just like well there was oppression you
know something happened to victorian
women 10 years ago
that kind of thing that that's why i
can't do this facts um you can
you know you and then
there's this whole like believe women
think this like you don't you don't have
to be accountable to anything so of
course you think you're god if i get
more too many compliments a day i think
i'm good imagine if you were getting
compliments and told you were the center
of universe from birth and then people
were saying hey man yeah get married
what is margin told a man takes care of
you that that's why they're narcissists
the whole dating game is for narcissist
you take them out you caught them right
there's no idea of courting for men
because men are told they're dispensable
women are told they're the prize it just
it just reached that mismatch now where
they have so much power and men also
kind of being beaten down by you know
technology and all the things are
happening right now that we can see it
but women have always been narcissists
outside
but and i think there's something to do
with the education system in the uk as
well because i've had two relationships
where as soon as i got a degree i could
see the change straight away straight
away yes the same day
they got that certificate that says you
wouldn't go a bachelor or whatever and
then what happened what did they teach
you this uni
what that's ended you have to end it why
because the women because what happens
is when a woman starts out earning her
husband she tends um she tends to
divorce him
if you don't bring me a piece we're done
what happened is she got a good graduate
job and then she thought she would get a
better man at kpmg or in central london
and that's what she's done
um it also happened with me in portugal
i met this gorgeous portuguese girl and
as soon as she came to london she
switched up i met her i was like hey
what are you doing i'm selling oranges
what do you like to do i like to sleep a
lot you have a dog this stuff what do
you want to do i want to be an air
hostess as soon as she came to england
in university now she's doing this whole
like aggressive like attitude black girl
thing of like oh you know i only want
peace now i don't want to deal with
anyone
she as soon as she got in this country
so what you're saying is as soon as
women get an education oh my goodness
that's it
get rid of them you can't that's what
you're saying no no no no no no you're
not saying you're you're looking to be
offended like when you say this like
you're looking to be offended that's not
what they're saying they're saying women
act like they're better than you once
they get an education that's the first
one is money can they be better than you
there can be also be a thing they can do
whatever they want
what kind of question is that would like
your if you're if like not in a not in a
like as in like i'm better than you or
less than me as in like
as in like you're bringing more they're
bringing more to the table now so no but
that means nothing to them so like like
guys don't care about your education
they don't care about your income they
just want to know that you're hot
hot feminine okay
let me take a picture so you met this
girl and she doesn't she hasn't got a
job
right so
you then
support her so she goes on and get that
degree
now she's got the degree she hasn't got
a job yet
right so she got degree now she's
looking at the potential i'm going to
end this and this month you know what
you've been there before the she got the
paper
now she then said okay i've got this
degree now so i can do this and then i
should change completely it's just not
easy to get along you should not easily
talk to anymore and you agree with this
it's just it doesn't bring peace so what
in the world are we doing together it's
just ego bro yeah i'm thinking fine go
and get your degree and i'll get pray on
the wall and go over there look the
problem isn't actually the education
it's actually the
people we know we live in a system where
feminism has been glorified and as a
result that coupled with education
causes women to act a certain way a
quote from c.s lewis he said that
education without values only serves to
make a person a cleverer devil so if the
foundation
is
there's a wrong mentality of you know
independent woman boss babe all of that
stuff and then you add a layer of
competence to it now i have more
ammunition rather to not to add value to
my relationship but to fight in my
relationship how do i support power
so basically that's what it is it's that
wrong dynamic they're building from the
wrong foundation basically but education
isn't the issue like you can have a
smart woman and yeah
feminism
some of the dumbest girls i know are
educated though
like i think honestly like i prefer
people that are less educated because i
think they're smarter
because like i think i literally think
college teaches people to be idiots in
what way in what way because it's like
they get indoctrinated even in schools
like i remember oh my god like i in my
college i was an economics major and i
had a teacher that was telling you that
the reason that um
like prices were higher in poor
neighborhoods because they like didn't
like poor people basically like that's
indoctrination because the reason prices
are higher in poor neighborhoods is
because they steal more and usually the
distribution is more expensive so that's
why the prices go up it's just stuff
like that like they
they teach you
propaganda in schools
another example of that i i used to date
this uh feminist german girl and she she
she was in king's college right one of
the best universities in the world
um she was taking this class and she was
just sending me this stuff from the
class it was about like um eco-feminism
this idea that women we destroy the
environment because the environment is
like nature's gaia which is a feminine
it's a goddess right and so that's
another way of defacing the feminine
and that and that you know and that's
men toxic masculinity extended to like
our choice in like toiletries that men
like shampoo that smells like masculine
things and like grenade shaped soap and
that that was an example of toxic
masculinity and she was like mocking men
and saying people are so dumb this and
that and i was like bro i have a grenade
soap
what's wrong with grenade shape so
you have a problem with the shape of my
soap now
this is like a like a a woman with like
top class degrees on a scholarship from
germany as academic as possible but also
not not the sharpest in the box in some
ways
and and like the other thing is they we
have women's studies how sexist is that
why do we have women's studies we don't
have men's studies what's women's
studies you've never heard of like
gender studies women's studies yeah but
women are complicated so i couldn't
understand that
women are not complicated but they don't
know what they want no they just lie a
lot they're not complicated just if you
watch what they do women are not
complicated at all i agree with that
like i refuse no no
okay how do you explain this a woman
gives a relationship advice and then she
goes and do exactly the opposite yeah
because she's playing you for a donkey
she's she's testing whether you're the
man in it if you ignore if you do
exactly the opposite of what she says
she'll actually be more attracted to you
because she's more familiar with you now
and you've shown you have balls
everything they say is a test you know
it's just lies
like you just made up like women will
try and convince you that they they wear
skinny clothes because they just enjoy
wearing skinny clothes they'll try and
convince you that like
paying for them doesn't mean anything
but then they'll demand it as well and
then dance to get into it they'll try
and they'll try and claim that like that
you know that they like equal
conversation and it's fun i'll i will
check your hinge profile right now
and what watch who you're interacting
with and i'll watch how much that guy
has been saying and i guarantee you it's
the guy that said not very much he's
probably very good looking though
[Laughter]
you're just spitting facts today
the devil is a liar
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna read super
chats for a second
guys um all super chats go towards um
updates in the studio we're also trying
to save money to get a bigger place next
year we want to do all different types
of content so i'd like to do like like
dinner talks where you eat dinner and
like discuss a different idea
and so
so the money that you guys send is going
towards our rent next year and that's
why right now memberships is so
important because
um that really helps have as the state a
sustainable
source of income
um that can we can use every month so
i'm going to read the super chats it's
all going to be about me
i need you to stop talking so i can read
it
also um we're going to members only now
jess if you want to turn it on to
members only
um for the second half of the show why
aren't the super chats coming up hold on
guys
um
details
oh i know i'm in the wrong spot
hold on one second
[Music]
sorry monetization
supers okay
so we got albert um retro follow-up you
tie somebody up and remove their
clothing without consent that's sexual
assault zeus did this to thor
no excuses accepted the savvy ninja had
to work to do
had work to do today at moa summer time
and literally thought if i wanted to
deal with the attention i'd
get wearing a tank top i wore it dealt
with the attention shame on me if i
complain about the privilege that i have
take a hike um miscap and tap you're
unbelievable rest assured that is not a
compliment it's a pity that you aren't
able to cash cash the reality check that
the show is trying to give you pearly
looking lovely as always doc mcgee i'm
not offended by that by the way
thank you
um doug mcgee i feel like the lady on
the right can only date bettas when she
said her man loves to talk it confirmed
it nightingale um he got his camera now
to get a better ac unit unit yeah the
camera for ish is coming on saturday ish
is on vacation right now but he comes
back on saturday 90 free topay look up
love stories guys will would chase until
they got a yes after that the ladies
said they were so happy they said yes
after having a family most women will
miss out because of a temp feeling ata
his
temp feeling i don't know what that
means um
ata his skirt turned into pants this
episode
i told you they're gonna switch on you
i'm the same
change
nightingale time to invest in some fans
or a better ac unit yes please look it
guys i want to get an apartment with ac
next year so i don't have to put my
guests through this for real sign up for
memberships um alistar horton i'm
seriously resisting the urge to post the
question to humble any woman with an
over-inflated ego monkey you sup i bet
my whole life savings the tattoo girl's
boyfriend is miserable being with her
and he is cheating with a peaceful girl
the uk economist an ugly man equals
harassment
chris hemsworth equals a compliment
albert retro stop sexualizing women
meanwhile they are laughing cheering and
eroticizing thor for being sexually
assaulted by zeus in their current in
the current movie
matt butcher ladies are politicians
watch what they do not what they say
northwest pearl pearl you're turning
into myron games in front of our very
eyes we can see you losing patience with
these silly girls i feel like merch the
uk economist your asian guest on the
sofa is cute is she single she's not
right he said yeah she's taken stay away
um chad chad b there is a concept called
symmetry of logic and logic and it is
intellectually irresponsible to claim
the exception to the rule is an equal
balance to the rule itself jacob
mckenzie
most guys struggle to just get girls
never mind if she's attractive but a lot
of girls are out here with boyfriends
and have other guys lined as backup
girls will never understands men
understands men's struggles matt butcher
tall girl tat girl lives in an alternate
reality bubble ey there is a video where
tupac was saying that women was saying
he was too nice and kept skipping him
this they skipped tupac when he was nice
think about it
brilliant madman i agree women will
dress nice to hang out these days
however that is because they are
constantly taking photos to be
objectified on line that's a good point
warren makeup is literally dr strange
sorcery gus sexual attraction is not the
same as relationship attraction just
because you look at 53 men will hit
you'll most likely be going through
menopause
warren the internet is a great invention
by men unfortunately social media has
polluted the minds of women by
influencers and superstars imagine if
women couldn't post on tick tock ig
their life would crumble ey the girl in
the white take white tank top is
responding dishonestly to defend women
no men don't go for 55 year olds not i
don't know like tank top girl says matt
butcher pearl for more likes say
something during the show lots of us are
mostly listening while on our grind matt
butcher ladies play stupid game wins
wins stupid prizes take a hijack a show
so nice we get the sound twice
um let me refresh it just to make sure
there are no more and then i'll go to
the next question
okay um richard harrington 1 800 people
watching but only
27 likes wtf yeah guys like the video we
should be at what are we at 1 900 people
here we got 500 likes are you guys
kidding me get to a thousand likes okay
a like is free if you're gonna ninja
watch and not subscribe at least like
the channel or like the page trilla 72
hey pearl the guy across from you is
fire too much truth hashtag not
complicated you guys are just liars
nightingale eating with pearl and facts
a fuller person is a more agreeable
person
melvin casher my man on the left is on
smoke preach broski um albert retro
follow up oh that's the one we already
read that so question
do you guys think that girls wearing
makeup is the equivalent of a man
photoshopping
his dating app profile
absolutely
i saw a really good example of this uh
you know snoop dogg's like daughter
yes like she's she's she's an average
looking lady
and
i've noticed you know
she has a very attractive boyfriend a
boyfriend is like some model with
creative design like you know very very
two different types of aesthetics going
on there
and when when people say
you know that she's attractive they use
a picture of her in a certain angle with
a ton of makeup on
which which is is kind of funny because
if if you said she was beautiful you
show a natural picture of her doing
natural stuff but you have to use a
doctored photo to make that point which
i always think kind of contradicts
itself doesn't it
i think it depends how much also how
much makeup is being used yeah because
there's i've seen certain um quite scary
instagram like videos where you'll see
someone without the makeup and then with
the makeup on it's a different person so
there's that level and then there's the
level of you know just trying to maybe
enhance
a little lash and then obviously
sometimes people compare that to
a guy's shape up and you know when women
get that spray thing but obviously it's
not the same still
but obviously there's a difference
between completely augmenting your
reality
and
you know just trying to enhance what you
already know the advice i give people is
if you meet a girl that you're taking a
date and she's got tons of makeup take a
swim
then you see you see what she looks like
what do you guys think is it the same
i think it's like talking you're talking
your mic a little bit i think it's like
when a guy has a beard
kind of the same thing
i think there's a difference between
like light makeup yeah
that's what i was gonna do the girls
that cake it on yeah they look
completely different i feel like you can
tell though like if you're like close
they're like crusty and yeah it's like
falling off
we know the one night stands from there
yeah and you wait and the pillow the
next day is
you notice the ten pounds of makeup on
your face in their face i'm shocked it's
just about it's quite dark in that but
you're a detective it's like jedi jedi
skill isn't it yeah but personally
though a woman that wears makeup just
got no right to tell amanda it's ugly
that's true
because remember the amount your man
you're complaining or you're talking
about he hasn't got makeup on that's not
true do you ever you ever hear girls say
oh he's medium ugly i'm like sis that's
just your level
says
like
because girls will sleep with a guy and
they'll they'll think that's their level
but it's not your level he didn't commit
to you you're side chick
but what about the girls that are
prettier they wear a lot of makeup but
they're actually prettier without it
i mean why go through that trouble yeah
then why would they do it i don't know
society they wouldn't they wouldn't it's
not society they wouldn't
they wouldn't do it like girls you get
responses based on what you do so they
probably get more attention when they
wear more makeup that's why they do it
so i'm a photographer right so my whole
industry is women men right people
looking good
so there's
hundreds of women that look and i okay i
guess i'm biased right because they're
models so they they look good
but there's a lot of people out there
that look just as good if not better
without makeup but they still choose to
wear makeup so do you still think that's
fraud
absolutely you said you still think it's
fraud even if she looks better without
it on
to you to you
i've met a girl that says she can't go
out of the house without makeup on
because she'll feel naked
i couldn't find it i just don't
understand that logic
she is naked in the brain
so if you look good naturally why in the
world you're swapping natural beauty for
man-made beauty that doesn't make any
sense i think sometimes people do it out
of you know just
uh talking about sorry yeah i think
people do it out of
yeah just wanting to conform like i
don't want to be the odd one out there's
this discomfort in
being someone who's different
it's it's also because in my view it's
just another layer of abstraction and
women like abstraction so
so if
if if she can make it more complicated
if she can add more and more layers to
try and like mis you know put available
the truth she's definitely going to do
that we've got makeup um
what kind of clothes she's wearing the
the the everything it's not expression
though
is it not like because like i
i don't know i don't know when this is
but how long has makeup been around for
because i'm pretty sure the egyptians
will make up i'm pretty sure the
victorians will make up like i don't
know anything about the history of
makeup
makeup is
20th century
but that's about makeup in general right
how long has that been around for but it
used to be for movies in the past before
i become generally no look at the
egyptians the egyptians all were like
i don't think it's anywhere near the
level as it is
i don't think you saw the egyptians like
looking like a whole different person it
was probably just like wings
if you apply if you apply so much makeup
that you look completely different then
that's a problem right
it's a scam i feel yeah
do you feel like you look different
without makeup on oh yeah of course i
look a bit better but i i tried to do
like really thick makeup i just think it
looks really bad
personally so if i'm with my boyfriend i
don't wear makeup because
can i ask so from your two ladies
you can contribute to this as well so
why why would you say you wear makeup
i do it because i don't have eyelashes
like they're very light and so that's
why i really only wear mascara usually
or if i have like acne and i want people
to see it
so that's why i wear it but
like i'd be lying if i said not to like
i want to look better
the
okay honest
how about you too
i think for me it's just
kind of like manners a bit it's kind of
like
a step for women to look more
presentable but if it's like day to day
like if i'm with my boyfriend or friends
like i'm not really going to like
go all out all the time because it's
it's just a lot of work but if like a
show like this or dinner
yeah i'm gonna put makeup to look nicer
of course
okay that's asian culture right isn't it
japan and korea like it's seen as just
manners like yeah i mean like you want
to look the best that you can to the
people you
you're meeting
or like if it's like a formal occasion
like of course you want to look better
but if it's like day to day i don't wear
makeup i think it's just too much hassle
personally i think there is a logic to
that actually like probably in the 90s
early 1900s where even men
it was culture to just wear a hat
everybody had a hat like if you didn't
go out without a hat you were kind of
like naked or seen as
something's wrong with the town of your
dress so that that thing of um
yeah man is it i can see the logic too
yeah okay this of interest how about you
i agree with that but also like i feel
like it's just an extension of your
personality right because there's loads
of like artistic makeup that you can do
as well as just like eyeliner i guess of
your personality do you know all right
for me
um
it's a strange personality you got there
thank you
um
question i also i get a lot of these
questions from it's complicated channel
so you guys should check him out if you
ever get the chance he's very good
interviewer
why are men shamed for lusting after
women
but women aren't shamed for lusting
after money
are they shamed for busting after them
you just shamed a guy for lusting after
you yeah harassment you said rasman you
call it investment yeah
i guess it depends on what way you're
doing it like if you're
if if i'm like so big that i'm going
after guys like as in like i'm gonna
hunt you can 100
see that like all i'm there for is like
it's just for the money then but if you
ask women what they want one of the
first things they say is ambition why
aren't they shamed for that like the
same way a man if he says big tits he's
going to be shamed
like that big titties
environment as possible to inject
whatever ideal best suits you so if
you're in a situation where the woman
wants you to say
physical physical physical physical
characteristics then it's cool and if
not that's also a cause so the point is
to blur the lines between reality so
much that i can actually tell it's like
hypnotism
you know i give you a lot of words on
top and then i actually slowly inject
what i actually want you to to do that's
why
they don't they can't fit with whether
they want ambition or love or kindness
or a tour guide or just anyone or good
sex or protection
it's that's why
what do you guys think
um
[Music]
i think
it's a bit of like accountability for
women i guess
because like
if guys are open and it's okay for them
to be like i want a size six
like i want a girl that's size six or
something then girls have to do it
so
like they're like okay don't say
anything that's so true because if men
say what they want then we have to do it
and then women don't want to like they
don't i feel like modern women are lazy
they're so lazy
and women just love money
i don't
i don't get it
guys
but i think with
money will make him look pretty yeah
dude do you just do you feel like you
live in reality i just found you
i just feel like i don't know i just
i've just i just grew up differently all
right listen
go to a therapist and like figure out
what your issue is with that word right
yeah just figure it out
because it's not what is so you're
saying like the way i feel is reality
but let me let me change that word
because i'm using it in in place for
think right
i need to go back to what we were
talking about um
i think i think it's because
i've just been raised i've been raised
by like predominantly men right so i
even though i hear what everyone is
saying i don't think it's always true
so
i've also been raised around women that
haven't
are like quite traditional so they're
not really going for their men
because they because of their status or
because of money they're going for them
because they love them they get on
question
so you were raised by men
and traditional women yeah but you have
tattoos and you think any male attention
is harassment what kind of men were they
do you know what i feel like if i said
to my dad oh dad you know what these
guys are chatting to me in the street he
would be offended by that
sounds like a beta do you think any dad
wants their daughter to be
no i think i think it might have my dad
would say who cares
that's that's what my dad would say
he yeah like
any i just think that's like simp
behavior to like to
that yeah have a right to be offended
because someone complimented you that's
simp
you think that's the same that's very
simple you would want your child to be i
would i would i would tell my kid to get
over it like why do you want to be a
victim like modern women want to be
victims
like who gives a [ __ ] okay he
complimented you keep walking that's
what i'd say
i want my i want my children to suffer
as much as possible because i want
character
to suffer bro what did i have to suffer
hustle bro like
you want them to feel it as well get
bullied for five years and then figure
out i'll drop in and give you some tips
like a good you know
teacher and whatever you know in the
video games where the bot comes in yeah
let's bring back what we do
let's bring
back bullet i'm so tired of these hoes
never have been humbled ever in their
life thank you
no
no because honestly if you why would you
want to have you because if you've never
been told you ain't [ __ ] you're going to
think you're the [ __ ] all the time like
sometimes you need someone to tell you
you ain't [ __ ] you know how lucky i was
to be grow to grow up fat
that humbles you that humble i'm so glad
i had a brothers to tell me i was ugly
sometimes
that's what brothers do yeah it builds
character but
guess what i've got two of them yeah and
i'm saying but you're i'm saying let's
bring it back let's bring back bullying
why thank you austin i appreciate you
why why
why bring back that
sorry i don't know
it's an important part of human
development brain development is to
understand
your place understand that you aren't
you won't have like the mainstream view
all the time you can't have consensus
that chaos is really important for kids
growing up look i don't want to have the
mainstream view but i also don't think
bring back bullying that's ridiculous
come on like bring it back i got bullied
i'm dope it's cool yeah i mean you can
be here people people it's like some of
you some of you have never not been
invited to a party and it shows
some of you have never showed up on
monday and said wait there was something
going on this weekend what do you guys
do it shows it shows
like like why do you think men tease
each other like
women say oh it's toxic masculinity
we're trying to have this consensus
around not thinking and doing things
that are toxic no it's because bnt's
teaches you to distance yourself from
words and what you actually are they
actually get hardened to it if i tell my
son your donkey you're silly you're
looking weak right now in in the right
way right i encourage him what is the
right word but how is that the right way
because you don't know how that's going
to affect him that later on down the
line
personal trainer says says you're
looking weak right now you can do one
more you know ex that kind of motivation
but insulting at the same time if the
average at best girl had been told she
was average before it wouldn't have been
such a shock
if she actually had to deal with reality
it wouldn't have been she wouldn't have
had to call into some random guy's
youtube show to be told she can't get a
six figure guy but that's what happens
when you let women live in delusion for
too long as they start thinking they're
they're they're qualified for something
they're not
and you see it all the time in like just
day-to-day
it breeds self-awareness and you need
that you need self-awareness you can be
self-aware though without without being
bullied but you don't even let me call a
girl a whale even though they are why do
i need to cook blood i feel like i'm
sorry
i could say what i want this is my show
what i'm saying i don't have to agree
with it but you do that's the crazy
thing is you you know damn well they're
whales you know damn well they're fat
you know damn well that they're less
attractive because they're fat i'm not
saying i'm not saying you got to be a
whale forever i've been fat you can lose
it
like i don't know what what but see like
why is this offensive this shouldn't be
offensive it just
crazy who had been like why are these
women just complimenting me she said
like how you should i'm cute what's
going on here
imagine if men reacted the way women do
i i do that sometimes just to take the
piss
like like i had i had this
time where i was trying out this new
theory so i was like how about i just
make women feel uncomfortable all the
time
when they approach me for no reason just
just to see whether it has an impact and
it turns out they love it because when
you make them feel uncomfortable they
think you're the superior social mind
they think your higher status making
people feel small is a very effective
way because actually they need to feel
sad wow because they're arrogant anyway
so it's like resorting to things like
that because of how the date marker
currently is and do you know what that
is that's fair enough right because i
guess like out of trauma or whatever
you're doing what you're like you're not
liking a circumstance and you're trying
to trauma i mean
it's not
it's just saying like you're saying you
got called fat when you were younger so
now you're gonna call someone else fat
is trying to make them feel bad i feel
like that i'm just like it's not to make
them it's not no no it's not to make
them feel bad or you know maybe maybe
they should feel bad enough to get on
the treadmill and run
that's what i did i ran out of money i'm
looking like i swear to god i hit i had
200 pounds you know what i hit 200
pounds it was the worst day of my life
and some dude at work like they were
saying oh i would never date a girl over
200 pounds and i and i and i carry the
weight better so like i'm taller right
so i don't think he knew i was and
and so i signed up for a marathon i
swear to god i ran a marathon
then i lost
and i lost a bunch of weight why so you
sign up bro because i because i'm not
lazy because i was like oh [ __ ] this is
a problem and then if you know what we
do instead we say you're not a whale
you look great you're not fat even
though that's it is what it is dude what
is with that and and you deserve love
that's the worst one everyone deserves
love
no one deserves
we do need to strike a balance story you
don't think you deserve all right you
earn it you don't deserve anything in
life but what do you what do you think
men deserve then if they still deserve
love everywhere
i feel like
what is the guy what is the guy that
approached you what does he deserve love
but you know why don't you give it to
him i said to him i said to him
i said to him because baby he's not for
me i said to him in my dad's accent as
well so funny i said to him so many
times in the nicest way listen bro i'm
not interested i have a boyfriend you
seem like you're a nice person i'm not
interested yeah please leave me alone if
you say that to someone a few times and
they're still not getting it do you know
what wait do you hear that
it's the world's small smallest violin
[Laughter]
the guy is running with you
does not tell you that he likes you
he's 54. how many guys wrong dude that's
even more impressive
running with you in the morning
my dude's putting in shifts listen
where's the love for that i didn't pass
out
that's borderline abuse like if a 54
year old was jogging with me just to say
yo you look good bro even if this gay
guy is doing that thank you my dude
thank you
do you think you have pretty privileged
i think all women to an extent have
pretty privilege oh i'm sorry
yeah yeah yeah do you think do you think
whales have pretty privilege
i love women you have pretty privilege
why was it cute you think you think
wales is a very nice do you think whales
have the same amount of pretty privilege
that you have as in the ones in the
ocean
is that what we're talking about i'm
talking about fair checks no i'm not
talking i'm not calling them that okay
i'm not going to like women whales let's
just stop that okay fat chicks no big
women bigger bigger women i'm not why
can't i call them what they are why do
you you
will shut up no but i'm saying like why
do you want to live in delusion because
they're fat they have more fat they have
more fat
i'll tell you why you're going to live
in a delusion it minimizes
accountability you can be offended and
it can be plausible at the same time or
it can be accomplished i feel like i
feel like you can carry weight in a
completely different way and it will
look different on different people like
there's guys right like it's like you
said you're tall who looks you carried
through who carried 200 pounds on you
and you still didn't look like you were
that big no i was kind of wailing it so
how much does your boyfriend weigh
when people are just like
plus size thing is like why don't you
marry a plus-sized person he's like
96 kg i don't know what kg is i don't
know what pounds it is
you were saying 200. i was like i don't
know what that is
13 stone kind of thing
what's that so that means he weighs more
than you yeah he weighs more than me
he's a bigger guy so that goes to i got
to show what i'm saying what that
um
uh fat woman that you don't like to hear
look at the celeb i'm going to say let's
go [ __ ]
girlfriend i think it depends on because
of what are you characterized as fat
because if we're talking if we're
talking about fat yeah there's a load of
girls 300 fat asses and you'd be like
300 where's the fat is it in the booty
one girl that looks good at 300 pounds i
don't know what 300 pounds is see i'm
going to use the word obesity you know
what 300 pounds is you know what a fat
goal is what is that in stone
what is 300 pounds in its own isn't that
like 150 percent yeah 300
pounds
what is that like is that over 15.
oh it's 21 stone 21 yeah name one girl
that looks good at 21 stone that's not a
whale i don't know anyone at 21 stone
in media i can think of a lot of
plus-sized models i don't know does
lizzo look good because you never look i
think she's cute
personally i think she's cute
do you think most men want to screw her
i don't know what most men do do you
think do you think she gets the same
pretty privilege you do
i don't know i don't know
i think you do know that you do know i
think i think i think if she was sat
next to you when your boyfriend
introduced himself to you i think you'd
have felt pretty confident
listen listen yo i i have a twin sister
right so i i had seen growing up she's
actually way she used to bully me for a
bit because i was like a hippie nice guy
when i was growing up i was like no
state it's not ego whatever but um
i i had the privilege of actually
hearing what women actually think like
women women don't say the truth on
purpose when they get together when they
talk with each other that's when they
say the truth that's when they say why
they get with this guy what they like
about that guy
do you do you think you want to keep
them fat so you don't have to compete
with them
like subconsciously yeah the other girls
right because with who though like why
you don't think you've got competition
yeah do you think you have no
competition i don't want to compete with
like why am i competing with them anyway
like it's not like it's not life or
death
you don't think you have to compete for
a man not really
that's a privilege okay well i'll take
that but if there's less wales it might
not be awarded to you because just as i
said just lucky for you lucky for you
there's a lot of girls plumping
themselves up right now so just being in
shape you're like a juicy girl look at
it look at you're you're in the top like
30 just not being fat
there's nothing wrong with a girl that's
got a bit of back like it's fine no it's
just yeah there's nothing wrong there's
you know when they got like the little
beanie bag on their stomach
like the
the human beanbag on their stomach
that's messed up man
like for me like when people normalize
this it's just like it's not healthy
they're gonna die young yeah
that's not good like i don't know why
people are like letting them die
i had a woman come on let's say obesity
is suicide yeah obesity suicide
so like but i'm not forcing someone to
be fat right but you're but you're
saying it's
you're supporting it as well
i care about them enough to call them a
whale to motivate them to save their
lives wow i i should be a hero right now
i
give her a whale ribbon right now i'm
i'm motivating them to get on the
treadmill look at it
if you love someone you tell them the
truth
ah yeah that's true that's very true i
think society has kind of dumbed things
down and made it so that everything is
okay do you do whatever you want but
trying to eliminate the consequences
but how like how it's not being able to
walk okay yeah it's not okay at all
diabetes but i do think crazy things but
it's still the way we should diabetes we
should motor because for example i run a
football academy right and there are
people if they are overweight the way i
would approach it i wouldn't immediately
say you know you're fat no i would take
them and then i will show them that you
overweight i will clearly explain it
but it won't hold on but it won't be a
case of me because obviously it's not
gonna it's going to demotivate them my
demand yeah exactly what i will do is i
will show them the truth
but i will also give them a way to
change that
so but obviously the thing that's wrong
with society right now is that we're
saying oh it's okay for you to just be
like that and keep doing what you're
doing and you deserve love
yeah but what would you do okay
why does this actually do costs
absolutely yeah that's my dose of
reality
why does someone else have to deal with
your problems because you have so many
health issues and now who's going to
take care of you the guy that's in shape
the thinner partner
i ca
and now you're saying they deserve they
deserve to be taking like what do you do
in your old age oh my gosh they have to
deal with like
how are you going to push them around in
a wheelchair when they're 300 pounds
[Laughter]
men don't having the problem turning
around as [ __ ] absolutely yeah you tell
you if you've got a fat friend you're
telling you need to go and lose weight
you have to tell him
yeah okay and the fat kids that were
bullied
they lost weight and now they're
healthier not all of them oh well
what about the ones that like took it to
heart and then
those ones shouldn't reproduce right but
the ones
the ones that did
the ones that were like oh wow
maybe i am fat and actually made a
change and actually improve their diet
improve their health
those those are the ones that are better
for and they're stronger individuals
mentally but my theory is i don't think
women actually want that to happen i
think i think that they kind of
subconsciously want to destroy
people and each other so i i think they
would rather tell each other that they
all look good because i don't think you
really want the best for each other i
don't i don't think like women sitting
with their fat friend telling her that
oh yeah someone's really going to love
you for you and like you deserve this
and that instead of telling her what she
needs to know because i know a lot of
women like this and they can lie all day
you know what but they're that i feel
and this is the point that i've been
like this is what i've been saying to
myself in my head i feel like
there seems to be like a lot of like
toxic behavioral traits that are
involved in these situations that you're
playing now and this is why i said like
i grew up different i love my friends we
all look completely different there are
people that are bigger than their people
that's all guilt and need to be right
you're shaming him what do you mean do
you have a fat friend toxic traits
dude but i'm not i'm not i'm just saying
that you don't mean you called him to
like this toxic and so i'm saying like
this is like the no i'm saying the
scenarios that he's coming up with as in
saying that like
oh
i was fat and i was bullied like that's
a toxic scenario it's not it's not toxic
that's what i'm saying like this is this
is the t i've done enough of these shows
so it's like it's like shame insult
guilt need to be read it's like the more
i like do these shows the more i
understand kevin samuels because it's
like the same tactics okay and so like
like when you don't like something
you'll shame it like you're shaming like
you're like you don't like that and you
don't agree with it so it's like shame
insult guilt need to be right but do you
think that like okay do you think that
you can you can't have friends that are
just nice to each other you can't just
have people that are just nice sweet i
think i think there's nice and there's
kind so you might you might say you're
nice but you're not kind because telling
someone that they deserve love when when
you know damn well that if someone's 300
pounds they're not gonna get it so you
can say oh you deserve love but it's
just not reality so that might be nice
but it's not kind
what's kind of saying hey get on the
treadmill and
and earn love that's kind i need you all
to understand especially women like
people that won't tell you i don't have
any friends that don't tell me the truth
i don't care about what you're saying
whether it's nice or not if you're
willing to lie to me for any reason
we're not friends i don't trust you
because i don't trust you to help me
align to the highest goals if you if
you've got four friends and you go
clubbing together okay and you've got
one of the those girls that no one talks
to
right so you go to a club they all fight
there's five of you
there's five of you you go to a club and
each time you go to each club everyone
is eating on you and your friends and
it's one friend that no one talks to you
what do you tell that friend
don't worry you're okay so you someone
will come talk to you these men are
trying to lie right
you're lying to me you're too good for
him misogyny you deserve better just
never settle they're fat shame in you
because a guy if that's so if you
deserve life
kindness with just like being lazy
because it's actually harder to tell
someone the truth telling you a lie that
makes me feel better about myself
because i don't have to be the harsh one
is not kindness it's just actually being
unaccountable and disrespectful to the
person it shows that you don't really
care about them you care about you it's
more comfortable for you to me to tell
you what i know you want to hear than to
tell you hey man you should probably
lose weight
i think i think i get some part of what
your sentiment is around we're holding
them around you know
yeah we don't have to say you're fat we
don't have to say you're this or you're
that but
or in in that sort of way but you still
have to confront reality and say this is
the
situation and this is how you fix it
rather than just giving a comforting lie
and saying oh everything's okay it's the
guy that's wrong or it's society that's
bad and all your issues are coming from
the external environment rather than you
who has all the power in the world to
change whatever's going on in your life
yeah so
yeah there is a there is a way you
approach it you know i think you're
probably looking at it from the
perspective of
um
you don't want people to be mean
yeah
that is actually what like that's where
i'm coming from that's one problem you
need to be mean sometimes
because bring back bullying because some
people are very stubborn especially if
they've been told their whole life
you're good yes
some of the most some of the most like
some of the most life-changing moments
that happened to me like were because
someone was mean to be honest and they
it inspired me to change
like even this channel right like kevin
samuels before he passed like i had a
conversation with him about this channel
and he literally like ripped it apart
he's like this is terrible oh my god it
was so embarrassing
yeah yeah and i'm saying like that
helped me because then i built this show
but like thank god he told me the truth
where someone could say oh he's so mean
no no no no no it's like okay but what
what do you need to hear
but i understand i understand your
approach though because your approach is
to ignore the objective problem and to
go into this post-modern there is no
problem and how i engage with you is
going to be based on feelings which
means that you don't really have to be
accountable because if someone fat then
dies of you know being fat you can say
hey man i was just being nice and if
everything's fine you can say hey man
i'll just be nice you can flip-flop
which is i think always the intention
behind modern females behavior
okay i'm going to read super chats for a
second
um
did you have something you wanted to add
you can go ahead it's okay i was just
gonna say that like
my point my point is is that you don't
always have to say things in like in
literally like such a harsh way because
it's like you're saying like are there
whales like calling someone a whale
guess what it's not gonna make them
wanna change like and like it's gonna
it's gonna make them feel horrible about
themselves and then maybe like not want
to be a whale anymore
self-reflect yeah
i think i think feeling horrible anyone
that's lost weight will say you had to
feel horrible to lose weight yeah that's
true yeah you can't you can't be
motivated unless you feel horrible
that's fair enough and all your friends
telling you oh you look great
wear that tight dress you deserve love
so you do you actually believe that
anyone that's bigger does not deserve
love i don't think anyone deserves love
i don't think an instagram model
deserves love how entitled are you to
think you deserve love no you earn love
be a good person
look good for your partner
and try to be what they want narcissists
deserve love
no one deserves a system there's like
enough love that like we don't actually
we have to like we can just give love
nothing no because they're using the
word like love with
respect so
yes in terms of how we treat each other
like yeah that's what i mean just
because they're fat or whatever but in
terms of earning social capital
that has to be earned you can't just all
deserve to be at one level or another if
one person worked hard to be here and
another person didn't work hard you
can't just say we're gonna put a quota
out that because we want to balance
things out we're gonna push this guy up
even though they didn't work that's
respect but love in terms of if you want
to treat each other and be polite and
have manners
yeah by all means
quota for dating fat jigs
that's basically that's basically what
body positivity is it's a fat chick
quota for me models but some people it's
difficult to tell them the truth and
love because you just once you said
something they don't want to hear it's
just not going to fly
then what do you do
okay so if you're fat right and in the
nicest way i'm trying to tell you that
you're fat you need to lose weight yeah
but you don't want to you don't want to
hear that yeah what do i say
because once i mention your
i can use any of the words overweight
plus size
you know where that condition is going
straight away your guts up
so i'm not
there is no like right way to tell
someone something they don't want to
hear bro
it's not i hear it but i feel like if
someone if someone's telling you you're
overweight and you need to hear it it's
like affecting your health you kind of
have to listen to it there's no like
there's no like i'm in an iron about it
it's just something that you have to do
from a guy's point of view
you're asking me like how to do it right
then you have to do it but then it's
like going to the doctor and saying
there's no feelings involved you lose
weight or you die yeah i'm not
disagreeing with you yeah but when you
start getting feelings i've got to
consider this that's what most men
become involved
when you think about it being fat is
selfish everyone has to look at you
[Laughter]
you have a fat girl in the sixth floor
that used to smell and then and then you
have to go on airplanes i got to sit
next to like why are you making me deal
with this and then and then who who
everyone has to take care of you when
you have health problems
right i lied to you
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm not moving for i'm just i'm just
going over there i'm just my legs are
just tired but we had a girl in school
that used to smell really really bad
like she had like she used to smell
terrible because she was overweight and
like you know that that kind of thing
like worst smell ever and
everything she would touch would smell
as well so there was one beanie bag in
the sixth form area that shoot that
beanie back smelt of her because she
used to
we had to build there was a lift just
for her no one used to be and you're
making everyone deal with that like she
had a personal lift for the janitors and
then and then they want to come on the
beach and make us look at their roles
i'm like stop it
put that away you have to earn a bikini
then try and bully me into liking it
say everybody is a beachbody
i'm so tired of this
when i was 200 pounds i did not make
anyone look at my rolls i did not do
that i
but but it's the narcissism you must
look at me you must appreciate my body
anyways i'm gonna read super chats
okay black is panther no one deserves
love no one deserves respect what people
deserve is human decency
melvin cashier people don't care what
you say people care and remember how you
made them feel when you say it alistar
horton a bitter truth is better than a
sweet lie matt butcher tat girl can't
handle the truth 90 free tope
truth equals love women don't love they
adopt men love ruma bruh i am loving
evil pearl looking
sexy today baby all the way from
tallahassee florida this is why she
already does this
alistar horton look up top love
moo voo doo yeah boo dookie 50 super
chat
stream sponsor okay birth control
reduced risks of promiscuity and allowed
women to inflate sex as their only their
main and only contribution to
relationships cooking and cleaning
became outdated men's contribute
contributions never changed and now
gender roles don't complement each other
alistar horton yes brutal honesty all
the way nathaniel
nanjo pearl is a hero we need more
people telling the truth december zero
eight one do not feed the whales sean
jackson if this chick found out that her
man cheated on her with a lizzie side
woman a size woman she'd be up in arms
because he cheated and he cheated down
significantly stopped the cap i know
that i always say the worst day ever is
when you find out you have to worry
about ugly chicks too it's like
you're laughing because you know it's
true
what do you mean
you know what i mean you want me to
explain it no i mean like i actually
don't know what you mean like what do
you mean everything is beautiful okay so
basically basically that like men will
screw ugly chicks too
but men will [ __ ] anyone right yeah yeah
so like the day like when you're worried
like your boyfriend's talking to other
girls and you see a girl and you're like
oh she's ugly who cares nah he's down
he's [ __ ] yeah yeah
um okay there scene 12 every time a
woman says got a yes or no question that
doesn't benefit the majority of women
it's just i don't know change my mind
equals w that's true oh my god that's so
true that is the truest super chat i've
ever got in my life i've been doing this
for months guys let's do that again
every time a woman gets a yes or no
question that doesn't benefit the
majority of women it's just i don't know
bro oh my god alistair horton what you
mean if someone that size sat next to
her she would be through the ceiling
bruh they make us deal with it
evan mcelroy everyone needs love social
interaction and love is essential for
happiness but you but if you are a
crappy entitled person nobody is going
to want to be around you saying you
deserve something without earning it is
ridiculous voodooki thank you for the
super chat desert fox everyone doesn't
deserve love they deserve the chance to
find it being overweight is a sign of
how you live your life 90 free topi men
tease to know if you're a baby or not
women can't handle because they are weak
not all men but most monkey you stop
this is why you stay away from tattoo
girls ata bully is a wet song tools to
sharpen knives honest citizen you can be
honest and tactful
bullying is moronic 90 free toe pay a
simple billionaire female will never get
or keep a man
a simple male will always get or keep a
woman your money means nothing because
it's not ours monkey you stop she's a
professional victim alistar horton
that's why most modern women's egos are
so fragile it makes eggshells jealous
david g was bullied as a ginger raga in
australia and it taught me how to fight
and made me resilient and resistance to
group think wouldn't change a thing jay
doe you ever think about how like in the
old days they're just they're worried
about being alive
so it's like bullying wouldn't have even
like they probably see us nowadays and
think we're so soft they're like you're
worried about bullying you're worried
about words
no one care did not do that yeah they're
like we're just trying to we're just
trying to survive your dad would like
join in he'll be like they're bullying
you you must be a [ __ ]
let's be a [ __ ]
are you walking out my house and getting
bullied by other people's sons bro are
you mad
[Laughter]
jay doe she is the same one that
wouldn't want a man's help if mugged
baby blue 1877 thank you for the super
chat um
i'm not reading this username maximus
attention to women was the same as corn
for men 90 free topi egyptians wore
makeup to block out the sun
mr negative so many women educated
beyond their intelligence
zac zaccn12 i just joined the stream and
while i don't want to be sex while i
don't want to be i i need you to not
talk when i'm doing the super chats um i
just joined the stream and while i don't
want to be sexist but normally i only
seen girls with broken i don't know why
you keep doing it like when i said don't
do it it's quite rude um i i just joined
the stream but while i don't want to be
sexist normally i have seen girls with
pants but why is the guy wearing broken
pants
jay smith great work the savvy ninja
they have men's makeup now i saw it at
target about a month ago i would not
hold it against a guy who buys it
equality right jay doe lies most broads
look like danny glover without it
vera
sac siva vong pearl you're a savage
spitting the truth richard harrington
1800 watching only 27 likes guys guys
how many likes we got we're at 1.1 000.
there's 2
300 people in here yeah we need to get
to 1 500 likes this is not a drill
thrilla 72 hey girl guy across from you
is just fire too much truth not
complicated just a liar i'm gonna
refresh it really quick and just to make
sure there's no more
like the video guys come on stop ninja
watching the audacity of some of you
maximus my name is actually richard
thank you k-thot swiss thank you for the
super chat 90 free topaz girl be a mom
to someone else you're not our mom the
uk economist if there's no difference in
being fat then why wouldn't there be a
lot more of a successful men choosing
fat women over slim women black is
panther no one deserves love no one
deserves respect what people do deserve
as human decency
okay
um so my next question
is
why are women grossed out at dirty jokes
but those same women do those things in
the bedroom
i love dirty jokes
i
okay
my theory again you have a lot of great
theories i think about this stuff a lot
i had to figure out the game but um
again it's just another form of
abstraction right so they want to they
want to create an environment it's a
form of control women women
have really big egos the idea is i know
you want to [ __ ] me and i know you want
you you want to call me and all this
stuff
but i can't make it easy so i want to
test you i want to see you know what can
i make you believe
want to test your intelligence so the
whole like don't make a dirty joke about
me that whole dirty joke thing is just
it's just a form of that it's like i
want to control what you say
and see whether you deal with that
because if you still make that dirty
joke it's actually seen as attractive
right it's how to build it's how you
build sexual tension it's just the
context it's a way it's a form of
control
um they just want to abstract the truth
because then they can again flip-flop we
can say oh you know well
just having fun like women who cheat on
their boyfriends they say that right
we're just having fun it was just a joke
we're just making dirty jokes at the
same time they could also be aroused and
they should actually be serious
they want to deceive you
that's that's the point it's just
abstraction it's a narcissist way of not
being accountable but still having
control because at the end of the day
they will find out where you stand first
and then flip-flop based on that they
want to play games with you that's why
masculine men don't talk in my video
because you're playing into this they're
using what you're saying
to to kind of try and plan how they're
going to approach you
women love to shame women
right so
if they don't if you've got nothing
to shame a woman for then
that's for her it's
game because if if she knows that you
you're into this and she's in the same
thing but you don't know then she can
shame you because women love to call
women slot
i don't love it i don't understand it
and that's just one of those things
where if you don't know anything about
me then i can say anything about you
unless you've got no comeback
it's a game it's a game it's a game
what do you guys think you like dirty
jokes i love dirty jokes so i don't care
yeah
from that guy who lives next to you
the one that yeah what about if they're
funny if they're funny i'll laugh would
it become rape if he was just like you
know grape that ass
on the way to work they weren't running
would you
if he was running and shouting him fine
sorry
sexual harassment sexual harassment i
think that would be seeing a sexual
harassment though wouldn't it by you
okay
whatever whatever okay
what if a police officer walked by at
that time and they saw that would they
class that as sexual harassment i hope
not we would have some real
problems no he's not touching you he's
not harassing you like it just works
what is the definition of harassment
please
i will look it up give me one second
oh they've got those adverts on the the
post on the ground about staring
yeah i think those adverts
aren't good at all like his
direct attack on on men it's like
oh they're yeah
i love how they act like everyone
everyone's like a rapist
sexual harassment and this is the
weakest definition i've ever seen this
is why women use it so much sexual
harassment is any unwanted sexual
behavior that makes someone feel upset
scared offended or humiliated and is
meant and is meant to make them feel
that way
sexual harassment is a type of sexual
violence the phrase we use to describe
any sexual activity or act that happened
without consent
okay could i be honest i
so where's the line
like women really need to like
make it because like if you don't want
guys to make you uncomfortable then
should guys just not approach you at all
like what do you want but it's like
don't accept that don't they don't exist
they just want people but stay in your
house don't leave like
or just ignore it or like wear baggy
clothes like you can do something
or like what do you want then women
don't know chaos
they want a world where they don't have
to be held to any standards there's no
right way to approach women
and that's why you see so many guys just
walking away because it's just too
complicated now
i don't know if any of you saw that tick
tock where um a lady posted a tick tock
saying that she went to a singles
day and then no men turn up and then
loads of men reacted to it saying look
you've been saying enough you've been
telling us to leave you alone leave you
alone leave your land and then it
happens while you're complaining kind of
thing did you do yeah
it was actually not true there were
there were people there she just
videotaped the section and tried to make
it look oh really yeah again the devil
loves lies bro lie about everything lie
so much you don't know what's lie or
truth then then i then i tell you what i
really want to do why did so why did you
do that well i guess you start off a
conversation you can bash men you can
bash anyone you need to bring back shame
no let's bring back i was wrong what
shame no i didn't
she's all for shame yeah i believe in
shaming
yeah you should be shamed for being fat
being well yeah that's this one you
should also yeah you should be ashamed
for being a hoe you should be ashamed
for putting your ass on the internet
like like
i mean i honestly think culture is where
the women are like the most marriageable
and the most wifey that they have shame
and they know damn well that if they do
certain things they're going to be
shamed by their whole community so they
don't do them yeah that's definitely
true
and because we've removed we've created
[ __ ] shaming on all of these things
um of course i'm not an advocate of
people just you know shouting out
people's ears or whatever but there does
need to be a standard where we're
literally saying this is wrong and this
is right whereas people tend to just say
oh you know do what you want everybody
has their own life you know everybody
has their own view but the thing is some
of these things are rude in biology and
facts so we can't actually just say if
we feel this way
then it's okay i like the old ladies
that just don't give a [ __ ] anymore and
will tell you how it is be like yeah
you're a [ __ ]
a part of you that just loves them
because you're like yeah
because they tell you how it is like
there's a part of people that appreciate
honesty
and that's like modern women don't want
honesty yeah that's a thing in back home
in asia in general i feel like that's
why a lot of people
keep
um
their actions appropriate
because everyone will know and your
family will be shamed you're like it's
just not good to not act with you guys
you guys are the most swiped write-on on
dating apps for a reason like
not for real
like i mean honestly like i think that
that like asian culture makes better
wives to be honest i think i need to
move to asia but trust me
that moved to asia came back and was
like yo yeah a lot of guys actually are
moving to asia because it's just like
we
i feel like in the west like women just
don't appreciate men
enough like you need each other like
stop it
like you need each other to survive
they probably move into asia though once
you get that woman you can't bring her
back because you bring her back you're
back to school
they're trying to stop that in like
sweden or switzerland oh because you're
saying when she comes here she's going
to change yeah of course she's going to
change yeah but um in sweden or
switzerland i think they were like
they're stopping them from going and
getting because a lot of those guys go
to thailand and they marry these like
thai women yeah and the government is
the woman prime minister she's like
trying to cut down on those passports
but then isn't there a high level of
prostitution in thailand
so isn't so
yeah but when you marry someone you're
not sex trafficking
yeah i mean at least they're getting
money for it the girls here basically do
it for free
i mean hinge and tinder is technically
sexual
yeah and i think there's a distinction
between prostitutes and people just
doing it as an everyday thing there's
always been prostitutes for our history
but the standard for women in general
has always been you know yeah if you do
it this way you're categorized as a
[ __ ] or if you do it you know in a
modest way as in with your husband
don't you think you know you're you're
seen as a wife do you think it's kind of
offensive to kind of imply that someone
getting marrying a thai woman must have
something to do with the sex no i'm
saying because she was saying sorry i'm
saying because she was saying earlier
that in in asian culture
um the morals are super high but i'm
saying that like but like normal people
you have like
that's like a
different demographic
i think south korea like their single
mother hate rate is like crazy low yeah
they're stupid like i don't remember
what it was but they were comparing
different like cultural trends and
and like i think that's where the term
leftover women came from it was
somewhere in asia in asia i think it was
china it was the one child policy thing
oh yeah if you there's so many dudes in
china if you don't get married in china
you're like left left over
they have like because they had the one
child policy and it was all men right
yeah like there's like a huge like
is that because they got rid of like
loads of the girl babies yeah after
abortions
because they wanted workers in it for
the fields and stuff the traditional
rural people needed people to attend the
farms and stuff
um so
well in countries where people are
ashamed for indecency single parenthood
is very low
because who who
who suffers
when modern women are selfish who
suffers it's the kids
so it's like this culture of not shaming
women it hurts children in the end
because you have all these 304s trying
to be wives they can't be wives so they
leave and then boom their single parent
household who suffers the children
that's why i i'm really out here
saving society
by telling bringing back bullying and
shame because i'm
i'm kind honestly
can i be honest it's like
i think
women in the west
it's kind of nice to have if you're like
a single mom because you get like money
oh that the government takes it like
back home if you don't have a house like
in indonesia if you don't have a husband
what are you going to do yeah so a lot
of women stay
yeah but it's like
that you need that like yeah it's good
you're prioritizing the kid over
yourself because women are women are
bailed out of every bad decision they
make so if they sleep around we have
birth control if we get pregnant we can
get an abortion if we don't get the
abortion we can get child support if we
get married and doesn't work and we
leave we get alimony
so like whatever we do and and also if
you're a single mother you get money
from the government
there's nothing like that for men
no even so if a woman if a woman's bad
with her money there's women's shelters
so it's like you're you're paying women
for bad decisions so they're literally
paying you to be a single mom so if you
don't like and in asia like they shame
you they say like and here they say oh
it's okay you'll find another guy
it's like you deserve love
it's not even ashamed it's a shame on
the family
because you you represent your family
but one day the money will run out
though
yeah that's the money run out like you
need 2.5 million to retire at 65.
that's a lot and and the women own
two-thirds of debt
even though we make less money
that's why
what's why that's why because they
haven't got the money that's where they
get into it no it's because they make
poor choices
like it would see like that's this is
the common theme i have with women it's
like a lack of accountability like that
like me spending more money than i have
is someone else's fault it's your own
fault
you can't if you spend money you don't
have then you're an idiot
well yeah that is your vote so it's like
and nobody should bail you out like if
you if you spend more money than you
have then be homeless
if you if you have kids with a guy
you're not married to be homeless
give the kid to the guy so if it's the
other way around if the wife makes more
money
and she decides she wants to leave the
husband she doesn't want the kids yeah
does she have to then pay alimony to the
husband not typically no no but only
three percent of cases men get alimony
three percent in the u.s i don't know
what it is here
men get nothing can we just pick up
those
you finessed that
it's like adele's x right yeah yeah i
know i think he didn't even get it he
didn't i thought i i thought he did it i
i could look it up but i'm not actually
sure
a great example of what happens when a
woman earns more than her partner is in
scarlett johansson and scarlett
johansson she's been around for a while
she's probably dated every top guy
there's a reason she's still single
right she's cute
yeah she's cute she's left over she's
left over that she's dated like every
top guy in hollywood she's out here
still single but she did um one guy who
owned like some kind of fashion company
they had a relationship he had a kid he
was a stay-at-home dad they divorced but
you know she she initiated a divorce and
she was like slandering him she was like
in interviews and she was like oh just
for the working women out there i'm not
gonna go into etc kind of trying to
demean the fact that he was a
stay-at-home dad that's a great example
of the kind of subtle disrespect that
you will get if you're a stay-at-home
dad because naturally they won't respect
you
women can't respect people they have
power over
anything they have power over you
they're like tyrants not they're not cis
narcissists are the same right if they
have power over you in any way they will
use that to their advantage to
manipulate you because they want to see
that the point is to frustrate you
and and they don't give you
any control either like they can't
submit because they think they make the
money they think you're they're better
than you
that's like i tell people that when i
get married like i want like even if i
make if even if i made more money like
i'd want my husband to like deal with
the finances
because like i just
because i love it no i just feel like
that's a man's job
men are better with money
and like i haven't had a budget in my
life
you know and most guys do they're better
with money typically because it's like
biologically like we're
we we like buy things emotionally or
like we're more influenced by that stuff
like most marketing campaigns are geared
towards women because they know we even
i was just talking to a company like for
um brand deals and stuff and they're
like you need to increase your your
female audience like i'm sorry they
don't like me
like
men understand from young if you don't
have anything no one's bailing you out
so you've got to be wise straight away
with your money because there's no
shelter if you can't pay your rent
you're on the street it's because we
can't afford to
not live within reality otherwise it's
over for us yeah and if someone but some
women don't understand that though they
don't understand that that's how men for
men go to they just don't get it
yeah like like do you know if a dude
came up and down this podcast and said
yeah a girl was chasing me calling me
pretty
and
like that's sexual for
[ __ ] her them
and they're saying like yeah that's
sexual harassment people just be like
okay
if you don't want to you could but you
can come on and like any other room
you're in people would probably give you
the time of day like this is probably
the first time you ever get pushed back
because you're a pretty girl
i just think i'm a normal looking person
i just i don't i wouldn't say
that i'm like
no
that's just what i believe about myself
everything i'm saying like those are
good they'll suck up nah that's just
what i'm saying it's just you just say
you just say a lot of things that sound
like cap and nonsense and not true so in
your opinion if you break yourself out
of ten write yourself out ten what
number five
five i'd say like in the i'm in the
middle i wouldn't say i'm like a
supermodel
i wouldn't say that like i'm ugly i
would just say i'm in the middle right
because like anything above five is like
models i'm not a model
no i'd say eight to ten as model yeah
yeah there you go then
right
i don't know like i don't i don't know
what you're trying to
get out of me but if i don't like being
chased down the street then i don't
there how many women can actually you
think you think fives out of ten
maybe it's just like where i'm living
but i just feel like guys will chat
to any girl
like i don't feel like it's a me thing i
just
[Laughter]
no but i see guys just like
i see guys chatting to i'll see guys
just chatting to like you think they're
chasing whales down the street
which is funny because that's the name
of the whale from spongebob squarepants
no actually i introduced myself as that
sometimes i'm like okay
like the whale
i think it's funny but then people take
it too seriously they're like oh and i'm
like no
it's a joke it's a joke yeah but
yeah that's that's not that's not normal
like that doesn't happen to most people
and one day it's going to go away and
you'll probably miss it i'll be watching
this podcast like that
i didn't know what i had
yeah privilege is invisible to those who
have it
i just i'm just saying
i think that
guys try their luck and i think that's
what it is more than anything else i
think
guys will try and chat to like if
there's a hundred girls on the street
they will try and chat to 100 girls
because it's a numbers game for them i
don't feel like it's like a like a mere
personal thing that and that's where i'm
coming from i don't think it's a
personal thing but you thought it was
harassment i just don't like it and i'm
a lot like all right cool like
if you're saying like i'm saying
for me there's like i don't like it but
there's i don't like it and that's
that's harassment there's a difference
harassment is very positive like we have
to be careful with our words because
words mean things okay
um
i hope you guys watching yourself you
think you're i hope he's i hope he's
watching it
too don't don't run next to me
don't do it um
i like
i think it was character
characterized
that harassment is like behavior that
you don't like nice i honestly think i i
think they've i think they've changed
the definition of harassment over the
years
if you go to 1950s they would probably
laugh
i think the women back then had
cookbooks stayed with their with their
husband when they had a family across
town like the women back then were jeez
they would be they would think we were
the softest [ __ ] they used to
take right hooks and be like that's just
part of married life you think that's
all right though
just be like slapping your girl about
and nothing comes from that i know i
mean i wouldn't comment on someone's
personal relationship but
i'm like i guess if that works for them
i mean some girls like to be slapped in
certain situations and in what kind of
way
is it aggressive maybe i just
misunderstood the situation you can spin
it any number of ways but it's funny
because that situation will be
categorized as very very bad
and
i just find it quite interesting where
certain situations where women can
leverage power there's very clear
definitions
and then when other situations it's like
oh maybe this
so what so what example are we talking
about so if you say to a girl
nah i don't want ketchup on my chips
yeah and she does it anyway and you just
slap her
straight across the face you think
that's calm what about same-sex marriage
what do you mean one no one at a time
guys
so yeah what same-sex um relationship
where there's two women yeah and one
busy other one that's still not okay
what happens all the time though but
that's still not okay i'm saying
it was okay for no one no one cared
about like you know her punching up her
ex and all that i was wrong a hundred
percent that was wrong yeah there was
the whole believe women stuff you know
100 that was wrong her photos that had
no meta tags
i saw that and i saw it was like the
same picture but she'd cropped it
like
to try and make it look like it was a
different picture so i have a question
if you
this was a super chat from team f you
joe media if you think you're a five
what do you rate lizzo one to ten
i need to see a picture of her again
because obviously i don't i think i
think you know what lizzo looks like but
you know just to feed into this i'll
give you a picture
okay i think
i got blocked
yeah i met this american girl in
thailand this is this is lizzie
but she goes how did you say she was
cute earlier she is cute she's got very
pretty face i know but i'm like this
seems like not true when you're having
me pull up a picture when you said she
was cuter but it's okay keep going
she has because i remember she's got a
pretty face okay i think she has got a
pretty okay one to ten
i don't know pure five yeah
[Music]
i don't know because i'd say like see
this is better she's like maybe she's
the same as me because she's got she's
got bigger boobs than me she's got a
bigger bum than me
so is that a five then i'd say five as
well okay that's so funny what would you
do
i just want to talk to a girl that tells
me the truth what do you rate lizza one
to ten
like a three i think i give her two what
would you guys give her a strong two two
two one i mean she could be worse
like you know have some kind of yeah
okay two three
about the same yeah
you say a
anyway so do you see how you like you're
really not living in reality because the
whole room looks at a situation one way
and you're like claiming it's another
way
but i think she's pretty okay yeah but
you know she's not
i don't know i know she is to me because
i think she's pretty you have to say
she's great but you have to say to me
because you don't if we if we if we had
no no
it's reality like if we had scarlett
johansson in here
i would say scarlett is prettier than
her yeah you wouldn't say i think she's
pretty you'd say she is pretty the
reason you have to put i think is
because you know it's not true well it's
because you keep telling me that
everyone else in the room is saying
she's pretty to me
this is a really good dating tactic
though i've noticed like good looking
women will say they're unattractive as a
way of garning more attention from men
because it starts very interesting
conversation what do you mean like it's
another i love saying that it's another
form of distraction right if i'm no i'm
cute but i lie to your face and say i
think i'm okay maybe a four out of ten
and that creates a certain impression
that i can lend leverage against you
who are you going out with [ __ ] now
like masterminds like
a woman not saying it's not it's not
like it's just like in this room right
you know damn well you're not a five
like you know you're not a five you know
you know you're at least above average
like because you don't have five results
in your life you have been chasing you
down the street and so when you say
things like like and now you're shaming
him and saying oh like what people are
you hanging around but he's talking
about you
but i'm not trying to tactically
i'm not trying to tactically date anyone
but consciously
thank you women do most things
subconsciously it's like there's it's
like do you think we're programmed to
like just flow state you're programmed
to try and find value and to cause chaos
as a way of in my view testing men
because because you you prefer the men
that can see through your chaos that's
why people call me an [ __ ] and then
are in my dms it's like well i thought i
was like oh i've seen that yeah like
it'll be the
the people that are fighting like on a
show if they're going at like after
she's all over him yeah it's like
i've seen this so many times where like
a doodle like humble a girl on the show
and then after she's like in his dms
all the time
people find love on this show i'm just
saying you know
for at least five minutes there's love
[Laughter]
sometimes seven minutes
if they're lucky
if i'm
feeling but it just it just goes back
it's like shame insult guilt need to be
right like you're not it's ever it's not
just you it's like every like every
woman is always pretty much yeah there's
like exceptions like
you're pretty grounded to be honest the
auntie was pretty good but like i'd say
like out of every 10 women i talked to
like maybe like two three
are like not delusional
thank you yeah have you noticed that
like in tv as well they try and test how
much they can make you believe but
honestly like make you believe what that
like remember when they tried to make
being a fat guy cool they were like oh
studies show that women like dad bods
and that was like all over twitter for
like two months because they were trying
to see whether like men would actually
change and that would become the norm
but most men have an average body
they're like most men aren't like rich i
think most men are overweight actually
yes
exactly
so what's your favorite so how is that
how does that not count well what he's
saying is like
they tried to promote an alternate um
standard of beauty that
they knew is actually inaccurate as a
way of seeing whether men would say dump
gym culture and be like i'm going to be
the dad boys oh it was like a social
experiment yeah yeah that's what i saw
as because like dude you know a dad body
is not healthy but that was all over
twitter for a while i was like studies
show that women actually like a dad
thought they find it this and that i
thought that was really interesting it's
like it's like when some things you see
and you just know they're not true like
i don't need to study to tell me like do
i find a dad bod more attractive like
the only reason girls like dad bods is
because they know they can't compete
with the guys that are jacked for the
guys that are jacked that's why they say
they're like oh i love dad bod but it's
just because you can't get the guys that
are
jagged
true
i'm gonna read super chats for a second
um
guys like the video let's let's not be
rude okay let's get to i said 1.5 likes
we're at 1.4
so like the video right now
please don't ninja watch also guys sign
up for memberships it's going to help us
go towards rent i really want to get a
place with air conditioning everyone's
hot in here i'd really like to get a
place that's bigger we can do multiple
rooms have like multiple scenes
that we can film and shoot in so the the
memberships are really important because
it's like a consistent flow of income
every month and that way we can pay rent
so
blackest panther your opinion on female
beauty as a woman is irrelevant you're
not the one that has to date her men are
the ones that have to deal with that
crap team f you oh the i read that one
already um
oh shoot no team f you joe media so she
sits next to lizzo at a bar and she
would consider consider lizzo her equal
to the guys at the bar 90 free top 1 to
30 is the best way to scale women
why 30.
i i i could see it because i rate people
one to ten a lot and i always say like
like i'll give two girls the same rating
because i feel like six is cute right
but like not all sixes are equal i
always say this like some sixes are like
hard sixes and some are soft so if
there's one to thirty like you can kind
of differentiate a little bit because
the way the way i do it is i don't give
people sevens like the same way kevin
samuels but eight is like the prettiest
girl in a small town nine is she's
making it to hollywood on her looks like
nine and above is like just off of her
look she can make it to hollywood eight
is like prettiest girl in a small town
six is cute
five is just like normal and it's like
off of her face but so it would be like
i could see how that'd be helpful but
that's two too many numbers for me i
don't do math like that
that's i'm not smart enough for that
skill uh okay zaci and one out of ten
guys get the girl they want and one out
of ten girls get
get
wait wait one out of one of ten guys get
the girl they want and one of ten girls
get
they want at least get what they want at
least 10 um
f you joe oh i read that one daisy and
gaming um i bet you tap girl will leave
here just as the same way you came in
jay for she's average at best tatt's
been ran through she's a strong four 90
free topay adam made women by
adam made women his god by disobeying
god women made satan their god by
disobeying god not all but most 90 free
topic
women aren't funny because comedy deals
with truth uh mr missing 44 that's true
all female comedians just talk about
being a [ __ ] just like all these same
things so yeah i'm a horror like i was
with this guy like okay um
mr missing oh yeah like the video if you
would buy a bring back bullying merch
maybe we could sell those um zen 12
shame equals a standard that people
should should be but you know you ain't
zee cnn say say my first super chat i'm
just saying because what i saw
what i saw it was a bit wrong according
to me and in the literal way um i'm
sorry i don't know what your first super
chat was um
if you if you message it to me maybe
next show i can read it but i can't go
through all of them i'm sorry um voodoo
zuki um
what did cinderella say when she got to
the ball f
um
maximus my name is actually richard
thank you let me refresh the page just
to make sure i didn't miss any also guys
like the video while i'm refreshing this
i'm so tired of y'all i'm so tired of
you all it's ridiculous um
sentience what is up zentiance is one of
my best donors i'm gonna let's give him
a round of applause i haven't seen you
in a minute sentience where you been
um liza lizzy lizzo is a negative
indiger and the guest who said she was a
five is actually a zero because of her
dishonesty and inability to judge what
is genuinely undesirable she could be
above average as pearl says but delusion
is the leading cause of ed in men
blackest panther your opinion on female
beauty as a woman is irrelevant you're
not the one that has to date her men are
the ones that have to deal with that
crap team f you joe media so she sits
next to lizzo at a bar and she would
consider lizzo her equal to the guys at
the bar
like guys like the video um i think this
is all of them but i'm just gonna
refresh one more time to make sure okay
well um i think i'm gonna close out the
show um
why don't we go around say any final
thoughts you have tell people where to
find she's cute
okay this goes back to like with with
she's cute with a filter at a good angle
where you can't see she's fat and a
bunch of makeup to to
to be maybe a four anyways go ahead
so i would say that
a lot of the things that are happening
today in terms of how
mentally things women see things
are actually dictated by
a lot of people at the top and for
specific reasons at the end of the day
it's all about money i think so
if you look at uh some of the things
that we've seen are like targeted
towards women it's about the sales
making women feel good because they're
the primary consumers a lot of the time
so i think rather than us fighting one
another as men and women saying this
that the other
let's stop fighting each other and try
and look at who the real enemy is and
yeah if you want to find me on social
media
it's zion j zachary and you can find me
on tick tock instagram
or on youtube as well if you type in
zion mandate you should find me there
because i also run a podcast too
[Music]
i agree with everything you just said
um
yeah yeah again learnt a lot today um
you can find me
on astroelbow on instagram
thank you
um i think people should
work on their self-awareness a bit more
and
understand why they do certain things so
that they can actually achieve the
outcome that they want in an appropriate
way so that would be my biggest advice
for people and like get therapy it's
like the easiest way to do it in my
opinion
um men and women are different and we
should stop pretending like we know
what's going on i don't know their
studies
but at the same time
this notion of equality just
doesn't work men would always like what
they don't want or obviously what i like
and we'll go for it
and if women can just keep up and be
truthful then we will have a balance
of everything
but
if we don't then we're gonna have this
problem every single time
um
i'm on social i'm on instagram at
football club of riverside because i run
a football club
and
i'm also on youtube the link is in on
instagram
um yeah the modern dating game is rigged
it's pretty messed up out here
um we've normalized delusion
and narcissism to the point where
um
you know we accept that as
standard now
any any sort of lie is is socially
acceptable um and as men i think it's on
each of you
to
be accountable not just for yourself but
actually take a step forward and take
that accountability of yourself as a
direct service to society so you can
find me on youtube now on modern
masculine
and it's a channel dedicated to
promoting healthy perspectives on
masculinity and trying to sum up i do
like one minute shorts based on these
questions people have always asked when
you're younger like why do masculine
guys never talk as much and why do
people do this um and i wanted to
condense all my experience dating in a
dating game in london into one minute
shorts just to help the younger guys
because no one ever told these younger
guys why these behaviors were normalized
and i think we need to start
trying to make sure to codify
masculinity and give especially the
younger men the blue pill guys a bit
more of a scaffold to understand exactly
why they're experiencing things they're
experiencing
um and then there's two more super chats
thank you all for coming this was a very
fun show
um two more super chats one delusional
girls a seven eight to me still pre stay
pretty and insane my lady jaydo
the ish will stop when all dudes man up
patriarchy
um i think that's all of them okay also
guys couple closing notes one um i'm
trying to get to 20k on instagram so you
should go follow it it's just pearly
things
we also have a new twitch page new
facebook
page sign up for our memberships and if
you want to get on the show dm eddie his
link is in the description um
stop dming me about it i'm not in charge
of it anymore i don't want to talk to
you people
respectfully love you but
but yeah dm eddie
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell and we will
talk to you next time